the rich roll podcast hey everybody it's
rich and I'm coming to you today with a
heavy heart somebody who I cared for
dearly has suddenly passed away his name
was David Clarke he was a good friend of
mine and he was a two time podcast guest
and in honor of his memory I wanted to
do a couple things today first of all I
wanted to re-release our first podcast
which we recorded back in November of
2014 that was episode 113 it was the
first time that I met him and also I
wanted to spend a few minutes
remembering him with two very good
friends of mine who also have graced
this podcast platform in the past
Mishka Shu Bali who's been on the show
many times you guys know Mishka I was
first introduced to David by Mishka and
also Joshua Johnny who's been on the
show a number of times in the past bake
podcast favorite as well so let's talk
to these guys
Mishka Josh how you guys doing doing
good considering I made sure I eat
something before we did this so I I felt
like I would cry last whiff I had food
in my stomach and so far not working
good look yeah so for those that for
those that don't know David Clarke was
an incredibly inspirational man he's
somebody who is known for this
incredible weight loss journey that he
went on I think he lost something like a
hundred and thirty one hundred and fifty
pounds he was pushing 320 or something
like that at some point was able to
overcome that obstacle as well as
overcome alcoholism he reinvented
himself wholesale he adopted a
plant-based diet and went on to become
this incredibly accomplished ultra
runner somebody who ran Leadville he ran
bad water he did this thing called the
Boston quad or he
the Boston Marathon back and forth four
times he ran across the United States
with Charlie Engle and a couple other
guys and just yesterday we're recording
this on Friday May 22nd but yesterday on
the 21st he went in to the hospital for
what was intended to be a fairly routine
herniated disc procedure and due to
complications passed away very suddenly
so this news it's quite jarring and
upsetting and you guys knew him well
better than I knew him as a matter of
fact so I just thought it would be nice
to kind of remember him and share a few
thoughts on on what this guide meant to
you yeah you know dave was the first
person I had like I had I had been
following a bunch of ultra runners and I
had also seen weight loss success
stories you know
oh but dave was the first one where I
had seen someone like I had seen both of
those things together that made it seem
possible to me not just to become a
runner but to actually be like you know
a a prolific ultra runner you know
mm-hmm and that it made it it gave me
permission in a way to like hey I can do
this I'll be okay Dave did it and that
podcast sent in in 2014 I had just been
on not you know what a year before that
and I was thinking like I was something
like oh man I've never slight I've lost
over 225 pounds and I'm you know I was
about to run my first ultra in 2015 I
had signed up for it in it in February
and I was thinking I was like leading
the charge of exFAT guy you know and I
hear this I hear this podcast with a
even I'm just
completely blown away like he's already
there he's already done it he's doing it
he wrote a book about it and um it was
just a profound night listening in to
that podcast for and and learning of
Dave Clark for the first time and I'm
lucky enough to have been able to meet
him several times and share the mountain
with him in Leadville and and and just
visit and have heart-to-hearts over the
phone
talking through my back problems hmm
well he's just a good guy
yeah he was a deeply soulful guy and if
there's one thing you know about David
that I think stood him apart was that he
always was available like he always gave
back more than he received and he never
forgot that call the service like he
just showed up for so many people and
was such a massive inspiration to just
thousands and thousands of people what's
ironic is like I was actually podcasting
rich when you called me yesterday about
this and and one of the things that I
was talking about and and this is one of
those things that like I would think of
all the time when I thought about Dave
was possibility right because it just
takes it just takes one person to do it
to do a thing whether it's losing the
weight or whether it's running the race
or climbing to the top of the mountain
or it just takes one person to do it to
change the thing from being impossible
to possible hmm and Dave did that again
and again for not just for us but for so
many people that we know and so many
people we love and like a part of this
community around the podcast you know
that like you know with us it's
impossible to take that much weight off
and keep it off well Dave Clark did it
then you know it's impossible to run
that far that long well they've Clarke
did it it's impossible to to invert your
ego to just you know exactly what you
said of like Dave did effortlessly the
thing that I have such a hard time with
of just posting up and just
being there and and embracing that
challenge of being there for your fellow
human beings and and giving and being
generous day he was just a bottomless
well of generosity he always had time
for people he always had energy to
listen to them you know yeah yeah I
think you said to me you know when
people say to you Mishka you're an
inspiration he say yeah that's only
because you haven't met David work he
was one of the like before I've written
or published anything when I was like
just getting my [ __ ] together like
getting sober and running and stuff and
I was like doing these races and
starting to like maybe offer up to
people like oh yeah you know I used to
drink a lot and now I don't
and somebody said his name to me they're
like you should check out this guy Dave
Clark you know and and so like he was
when I met him dude it was like meeting
Superman you know that's exactly what it
was like I was like oh [ __ ] you're real
and he was relentless no matter what
mountain he climbed he was always I and
the next thing like you know part of his
disposition was that there was no rest
for David Clark like no matter what
obstacle he was facing he was always
finding that glimmer of positive
opportunity you know whether it's you
know look I've been injured in running
so now I'm gonna get on the bike or I'm
gonna go into the gym and learn how to
be an MMA fighter like there was just no
stopping this guy and he was also
prolific in his writing he wrote this
amazing autobiography out there
then he wrote broken open which is more
about the nature like sort of this dark
secret in endurance and ultra endurance
sports where our relationship to this
sport becomes unhealthy and his
reckoning and and kind of wrestling with
that and he just released this brand new
book like last week May 10th called eat
[ __ ] and die which everybody should pick
up especially if you want to support him
and honor his legacy I mean three books
and while he's doing all this other
stuff and in and facing you know the
kind of obstacles that that you know we
all face as athletes and
humans I I had a relationship with Dave
that was sort of like my relationship
with Stephen King you know whereas like
Stephen King has to write everything and
I would go on Facebook and see and did
and like Dave had just wrapped some
insane challenge donating all the money
he raised to this charity and I would
log back in and and he'd have another
[ __ ] one lined up like right after it
I was like God God did Dave like I
you're just gonna run to everything like
are you just gonna raise all the money
are you gonna help all the people I am a
dude funny he was persistent man and I
think that has a lot to do with like the
you know I looked up to him really you
know obviously as a human and as a
person who has lost a lot of weight but
really is an aspiring ultra runner man
now you know I've been wanting this for
so long you know to be one of those
things it was it and if he was not he
was just a guy that that was there for
me not only as an experienced ultra
runner to offer advice but as one who
was also morbidly obese at one point in
time and could relate to me in ways that
other people just don't can't you know
it's a really weird twisted Club he's
like I don't know why my heart's broken
so bad like these former Li morbidly
obese I know how bad you had to hurt to
get there and it just makes a certain
bond and to have one that to have one of
those humans that whose Venn diagram
also overlaps an area of of what we do
for fun like what we do for like
camaraderie and pleasure and community
is ultrarunning is like it was it was
especially unique relationship was a
with with with the runner although we
didn't get to meet in person off the
I did I did look up to him in us in a
very unique and specific way and he is
there's gonna definitely be a void home
and my wife yeah I think I think what's
interesting to John is that like the way
you describe it that's exactly how I
feel about him you know but I didn't
have the experience of being morbidly
obese and then losing all that weight
you know in it it's like it's a it's a
small weird club that we have you know
but like dave was deeply ours you know
he he belonged to us and he was one of
those people who like when you met him
he had all this strange amount of
insight into your life as you know as an
addict as you know somebody who had lost
all this weight as an ultra runner as
somebody as an aspiring writer it's you
know he was just [ __ ] was a
check in every box you know and I just
every time I saw him I was like man you
know me you know and he did from the
instant I met him and and I and I feel
like we all have that experience of Dave
you know that for we feel like he was
very specifically ours yeah finished in
each other's sentences the first time I
ever met him I think that there's
something really special and unique
about his arc in that it's not just this
massive weight loss story you know I've
known people that have lost tremendous
amounts of weight I know many many
people that have battled with and
overcome their addiction turmoil but
with David it's sort of like you said he
checked all those boxes but you know
when you look at these images of him
before he wasn't just a large guy lost
in the throes of alcoholism there was a
darkness to it like a deep darkness that
you can see in that guy and for him to
transcend that and step into the light
and be this beacon for so many people in
a way that you know I I struggle to even
think of anyone else who comes close to
you know that kind of example that he
set for so many people it's just a deep
and profound loss for for all of us and
the experience that he had in his life
you know struggling as an alcoholic and
an addict and and somebody redic today
and then you know addiction to the to
the racing to you know to all the you
know the crazy [ __ ] that he did the to
see him in person he just had those
beautiful big blue eyes like a like a
baby you know and in so it was like
every time I saw him looking at his eyes
it was like he was getting younger you
know and he just he was so so hungry for
experience and for understanding and for
knowledge and for empathy you know he
just dude was like a heart in running
shoes you know he cared about everybody
well he left us too soon
I believe he was 49 when he passed and
he will be deeply deeply missed he was
loved by many and Mischka you said when
we talked on the phone the other day you
said you know I will I will just you
know that guy is just tattooed on my
soul like I will never forget him like
and I think he lives boldly within all
of us and will forever absolutely man
you know I like didn't sleep great last
night he dragged myself out of bed this
morning and I was thinking about what
Dave used to say about you know like
every day it's a new opportunity to go
for a run and I was like you know what
he can't today but I can and so I
dragged myself out there and was just
out of in my head the whole time you
know and I was thinking about he was he
he wasn't fearless you know he had he
had tons of fear and I'm sure he would
tell you that he was mostly fear but
courage is feeling
fear and doing the [ __ ] thing anyway
and that was his special mm-hmm you know
and I I feel like you know at the end
you know that he was probably like oh
man so so this is it right this is you
know that the great race right one thing
I haven't done yet yes really well [ __ ]
it let's go man I've been curious my
whole life what this was about like
let's go for it you know and and I feel
like in my heart that just you know that
at the end he was like alright this is
the next big thing this is the next big
adventure you know I agree yeah well I
think that's a good place to put a pin
on it but before we get into this
conversation two more things I think we
need to talk about one is we decided to
set up a GoFundMe for David's family
Michigan a year that you're actually the
one who set it up to raise money to help
cover the costs associated with his
passing and I'll put a link in the show
notes to that if you have the ability to
contribute please do I'm sure it'll be
appreciated and and and much needed by
his family he's left behind by Courtney
his girlfriend yup and three kids right
yeah so they can use all the help that
they can get and the second thing is we
were talking about trying to figure out
some kind of community run challenge
that we can all do together to help keep
them in our hearts so Michigan you want
to tell us a little bit about what you
were thinking on that note so what I was
I was I was doing on this you know today
two wells on my run and thinking about
Dave and thinking about that he was and
you know his handle on everything was we
are Superman it wasn't it wasn't about I
it was about we it was about us it was
about community it was about all the
strugglers who was about you know the
whole human race you know and and he he
had no ego about anything that he'd done
you know he would be to say I was fun it
was beautiful you know how are you doing
how's your running been you know your
left foot was bothering you you know how
you were doing with that
so I I feel like now it's time for us to
take the light that he's Shawn on us and
shine it back on him and his birthday
was February 5th to 5 so I say a week
from tomorrow
that's what May 30th
let's all go run out and run 2 5 4 Dave
whether it's you know and I wanted it
seemed it was felt important to me to
make it a challenge that's open to
everybody because Dave when he started
running man he could only make it a
couple of steps because he was so fat
and so out of shape you know so go out
and run point two-five go out and run
2.5 run 12.5 22.5 you know what whatever
it is for you go out and do it keep Dave
in your heart keep me in your head
post about it we want to hear why you
were him how he touched you and I think
we're gonna use the hashtag we are David
Clark you know because he he gave that
we are Superman nos that was that was
his gift to us and I think we should
give it back to him I agree yeah I love
that so with heavy hearts we're gonna
bid you adieu now and hopefully
listening to this conversation or
revisiting it if you heard it prior
several years ago we'll bring him more
present into your conscious awareness we
are all David Clark that's true
we miss you Dave we love you and you
will not be forgotten so thanks you guys
I appreciate it and without further ado
this is me and Dave Clark
thanks for coming down man I'm glad to
be here
dude you made the trip all the way from
Colorado down to LA to sit with me man
I'm so honored by that I really
appreciate it if I'd had more time out
of run yeah a little bit more time right
what do you what do you been doing since
you've been in LA um I just been kind of
hanging out a little bit I got a chance
to go down and meet some folks at a
running store front runners and do run
there and the one in Brentwood yeah oh
no actually I showed up at the one in
Brentwood but I was supposed to be at
the one in West Hollywood I ended up
making it to the right one though and
got to talk about my book a little bit
and well that's cool
do you have a nice turnout of people or
what was it usually those things like
whenever I do that kind of stuff like
five people show up you know yeah I've
had both spectrums of the experience you
know that the five and the fifty this
one was like there's like 20 people that
was pretty good turnout that's cool did
you do a run also or yes talk about the
book no we did a run and I got a
hundred-mile er coming up this Saturday
so I was supposed to do a nice little
taper run and it turned into be like a
5-mile race yeah usually that's what
always happens when I do the group runs
like a lot of people that don't you know
they're not ultra runner so they God
they run a lot faster than I run when
I'm training I was getting intimidated
yeah you know yeah I think it was just
because like you know I don't know some
guy no one knows who he is shows up from
Colorado so everyone wants to just kind
of yeah Scott you know and it's hard to
not just eat get caught up in any end of
Breman fast of course if you look good
what's the hundred-mile are you're
getting ready for I only got two
javelina uh-huh yeah down in Arizona
nice man that should be good yeah have
you done so what races have you done
since badwater 2013 um well I did bad
water this year oh you did well actually
it did me but yeah I got I had last year
was just such a dream come true to get a
chance to line up out there and and to
do it and finish it and then this year
even with the new course I wanted to go
out and see see if I could test myself a
little bit against it and I went out a
bit aggressively oh you did yeah
you know a little ahead of yourself I
seem to learn the same lessons over and
over yeah well I could tell from reading
your sobriety story it's not a it's not
a linear trajectory for you nor is it
for me but nor is it for most people
yeah that's true
you know I was with I just got back I
was up in the Bay Area for a week and
yesterday afternoon I did a podcast with
Dean Karnazes who gave you a wonderful
blurb for your book by the way yeah and
we were talking about bad water and he's
like man I just can't figure that race
out like some years I go in I think I
have it totally dialed and it kicks my
butt and other years I feel like it's
not gonna go well and then I have my
best year or so he just he's like I
can't crack that nut yeah it's this
tough certainly he knows a hell of a lot
more than I know about that kind of
stuff but I've experienced the same
thing I mean I was I was fitter and in
better shape and I think even more
prepared mentally than I ever was but
you know that's the way ultras go though
it is it's humbling it'll down that's
sport you know I think it's a sport in
general and yeah I mean one of the
things we were we were talking about
yesterday as well as is the importance
of failure not just the willingness to
fail but the failure itself because
that's the place from which you can
learn and grow like if you had a great
race then what do you take away from
that yeah better than I was last year
back that's so true it's I mean it's
good for the ego right you go through
you have a good day but you never I
don't remember ever saying you know wow
everything went great
and I learned so much and usually
happens when everything goes really
really bad that's right you're right I'm
like a good stubborn alcoholic yeah
how has the the process of kind of
getting the book out there have been for
you you know it's been incredible in
every possible way and and you know the
finish line for me was always finishing
the book writing it you know and I never
really looked very much beyond that so
everything that's happened since then
over the last couple months has been you
know definitely something that I hadn't
anticipated and hadn't spent a lot of
time thinking about so
I've been very blessed as usual to have
some guys like Dean you know endorse a
book and marshal all right to write the
foreword so that's definitely helped you
know get my foot in the door have you
played Tim O'Donnell to gave you blur
Marshall wrote the foreword so you're in
good company with those guys right yeah
blessing living in Boulder too of course
right yeah yeah you throw a rock and you
hit a training partner that's right
right I always say that in Boulder if
you tell everyone you did an Ironman
they won't be impressed they'll just ask
you what your bike split was I'd be
scared to it they're too many too many
super fit athletes yeah yeah how long
have you lived there I've been in
Colorado for about 20 years and right
most of that was not in Boulder right no
mostly in the Denver Metro area and I
still live in outside of Boulder and
laughing and I live about eight miles
outside mm-hmm
yeah but you go into you do you find
people in Boulder to train with or are
you like a solo guy when it comes to
training you know I'm not surprisingly a
man of extremes when it comes to that
yeah but I could spend a lot of time
just you know running by myself and and
and I can be very social to you know I
like I like it all yeah and I like to be
out there in my own head and and stuff
and and also it's good to just you know
I've definitely benefited greatly from
being able to run with guys man girls a
lot stronger than me mm-hmm yeah it's a
that's that's what's great about that
community you know I still you know I
keep telling my wife and let's go live
in Boulder for a summer just for summer
you know I'm sure I would get just epic
training in you know I'm more of a lone
wolf though I like to go out by myself
get the quiet time away from the kids
and everything but but it's good to mix
it up with company I think let's uh
let's play a little game and I go you
know well it's called huh what it was
like what happened and what it's like
now okay you know that game right yeah
well what it was like man that's that's
tough it was it was pretty bad you know
it got it got really really dark and
really really ugly and you know I just
kind of you know created this this place
for myself where you know this
image of who I was and of course you
know I found a way to put alcohol and
using in the middle of that identity and
so it never seemed odd you know to be in
that place and and I had you know I had
like all of us a tough childhood and a
lot of things that were you know
disturbing me in there and and I was
running away from it and you know at
first it was chasing the kind of the
concept of normalcy you know and just
wanting to feel it attached to society
and owning a home which seemed really
almost impossible me at one point in my
life and and then starting a business
and being successful in that and all
these things I was I was chasing just
never really made me happy
you know so I tried to silence you know
those those those guiding voices if you
will from the outside in and you know as
I did that as I went along my chemical
abuse my substance abuse and it just got
darker and darker and it went from
partying and having fun and goofing off
to you know just sitting by myself you
know and in the dark and that night and
drinking and it's funny was like all
these things that I you used as you know
levels or barometers to gauge my
drinking and how I was normal at least
I'm not drinking in the morning and at
least I'm not you know waking up in the
bushes somewhere you know and one by one
although there's always somebody lower
there is I mean and you can spin that
wheel forever and I found reading you
know that aspect of your story to be you
know really profound for me I mean i
emotionally related with it completely
you know the circumstances of some of
your story is very different from mine
but it's the same story you know and and
what I what I what really touched me the
most was how you described this sort of
you know the drinking and isolation you
know I think that's something that a lot
of people can't really grasp I think a
normal person will read these stories in
your book and they'll think that you
know I don't like you know how does
somebody do that like I don't understand
you know and I'm reading and I'm right
with you you know it's like you know I
couldn't wait to get home from the party
so that I could really start my drinking
you know
so I could that's when the good drinking
starts you know and and all the kind of
shame that comes with that
and you know that progressive withdrawal
from society and you know as you sink
down then you're you start surrounding
yourself with lower companions but you
always surround yourself with the other
people that are doing the kind of same
thing that you're doing so you never
have like an objective mirror to reflect
the reality of your behavior oh
absolutely yeah it's funny because I
mean how could you expect someone who's
never been there to understand when even
going back and reading it and reliving
it I go how the hell did I not know what
you did no I mean you knew when you were
13 you know you knew on some unconscious
level that this was probably gonna be a
problem down the line and I I remember
sort of harboring that kind of
semi-conscious thought like you're not
really aware like oh I'm an alcoholic
but you have that little tickle like
early on where you're like yeah this
might not go so well no you're right
that it wasn't so much as not knowing is
like just how could I not you know be
actively aware of how destructive it was
but now you're you're so right now I
always knew that what I do in wasn't
exactly normal yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know drink when it's good drink when
it's bad and what's also interesting is
that you know in the midst of like a
pretty insane drinking career you're
still able to like put together this
amazing business and succeed and make
tons of I mean you must be an
unbelievable salesman because you know I
think that the kind of outsider
perspective would be if you're drinking
like that there's no way you can
function but the alcoholic is a very
resourceful individual you know very
scrappy and I thought it was I thought
it was very interesting how you
described how you were able to kind of
keep all the plates spinning for as long
as you did yeah I think that the picture
that a lot of people have of the
alcoholic is is woefully inadequate you
know like like you said it's you know
it's not the bomb sitting on the street
corner you know you know drinking and
sitting around in his own filth although
we can all end up there we stay on long
enough it's hidden it's heading that way
but no it's it's it's the guy
that's you know doing a pretty
reasonable job at creating an illusion
of what his life looks like mm-hmm you
know and and getting farther and farther
away from that illusion as it goes you
know deeper and deeper in right there's
this great disconnect and there's this
growing awareness that yeah this is this
is a problem you know you're getting
into trouble all of it I mean you know
you know you know that this is not good
you're powerless to stop and to
compensate for that you go over time on
work and all those other things because
you could that helps put the facade up
that your life is actually functional
yeah and I didn't it gives you you know
proof that you are okay you know it's
like hey well at least I'm doing this
you know and I'm okay you know right and
and that kind of feeling of the ego like
there's that episode in the book where
you're you go into that huge pitch
meeting right and you know you have you
know brass balls and you know you kind
of like throw down the gauntlet on this
deal like in a pretty risky way and you
get what you wanted out of that so what
I took away from that story is sort of
this weird thing that I think only the
alcoholic and truly understand which is
having this huge ego like thinking
you're you're more entitled and better
than everybody else but also
simultaneously harboring this like
horrible shame that you're a piece of
[ __ ] and you're worse and everybody
completely worthless and you know
shouldn't even be breathing air like
only the alcoholic can like entertain
those two thoughts at the same time yeah
the egomaniac with the inferiority comes
axial yeah yeah and the funny thing is
like looking back and reliving it and
writing it and you know I think maybe at
some point I thought you know I was
doing a really good job at controlling
other people and circumstances and
manipulating my environment but really
it was just me that I was manipulating
and controlling and those other things
you know those could have happened no
matter what just because you know I was
creating value in the industry that I
that I was in and I didn't have to go in
and and totally try to manipulate and
control but you don't know any other way
when you're now I have to control
everything that's going on right mm-hmm
you know and it's just it's obviously
it's [ __ ] it's a temper
can you control it yourself how you
gonna control they're going out right
let alone controlling 911 and then you
know the market crashing and everything
that happened to your business as a
result like all these kind of things
that happened to you
things are progressively being taken
away from you you're holding on stronger
and stronger to the drinking but also
developing this awareness that you know
you're gonna have to stop yeah yeah it
was it was an interesting time you know
it would have been really you know I've
always had this kind of like alarm bell
you know that can they can go off even
when when I was falling farther and
farther down the hole there's all these
levels where these alarm bells would go
off and and and I would sense that I was
you know dropping down another level and
that was certainly one of them and you
know it was really tempting and alluring
to to blame the loss of my business on
9/11 itself and and what happened in the
economic aftermath and it was something
that I just couldn't really let myself
do because I knew it was going to to
crush me and send me even farther
farther down so just try to move on you
know well play the victim is is always
the easy way out and the alcoholic is no
stranger to playing the victim no yeah
but I thought that your wife showed
tremendous or no your ex-wife but your
wife at the time showed tremendous
patience with you I mean she had to be
just coming unglued while this was going
on yeah that's a that's a tough subject
she was I mean she wasn't is an amazing
person she's incredibly patient but our
relationship was was very odd and and
very hard to really put in perspective
you know we grew apart
no no shock there with with my behavior
and in over those years but you know we
never had any arguments about my
drinking you know there was never that
that place it was obviously pushing us
apart it was obviously creating a lot of
damage in our relationship but it wasn't
presenting itself as a problem it wasn't
a topic of conversation I think probably
if I had to be really honest
it was because she was afraid of
engaging me in the debate because you
know I'm a reasonably good debater
especially when drunk and passionate man
I think she just had to step back and
and try to let me figure it out and
she's amazing and we're still really
good friends today but um yeah she's
she's some else yeah I think that the
most heart-wrenching part of the book
for me was the night that you stay up on
Christmas Eve drinkin super late and
you're just out of your mind and then
you realize like you haven't wrapped
these presents and you know you're just
unable to kind of get that job done and
and the presents end up with you know
masking teeth and we're just kind of
looking like a mess and and to kind of
shame the next morning of that dawning
on you and realizing that I mean I think
if there was ever a moment where your
wife would be like I can't I can't you
know I can't have this anymore that
would have been it yeah you know it's
funny like of all the you know how it is
like when you go about you know when I
started write the book I made a deal
with myself that I wasn't gonna hold
anything back nothing that I thought
would be too embarrassing or the things
I wrote about it like you know driving
drunk and stuff like that I didn't want
to put that in there cuz I didn't want I
know with the stigma that's attached to
that and I didn't want people chasin
after me but it's like you know I'm
gonna put what's in there and then if
it's too much I just won't release the
book but I'll have a accurate product
when I'm done and so you go through all
these moments these low moments you know
and and I chose a handful of thousands
you know and I tend to choose the ones
that were for whatever reason I was
present enough at that time to to
remember it but the reality was most of
them I didn't remember and I had no idea
what happened the night before but of
all the things that I talked about in
the book the the other addicts that I
talked to always point out the Christmas
present story and and not some of the
other ones like you know it's that one
and and I think because we've all just
been in that place where you're you're
you're so drunk you're so out of it that
you can't do this
stupidly easy task
and your brain knows you should be able
to do it and it becomes more and more
frustrating and more and more shameful
and and humiliating and and everything
all wrapped into one and I if if I could
you know if I would have written the
story as a script that would have been
Milo you know that would have been the
moment that I rose up from the ashes and
created a new life because I don't know
that I've ever felt less of a human
being than I did that Christmas morning
but I kept going well you know I think
it it it highlights well there's there's
this idea that the alcoholic will Harbor
that you know hey leave me alone I'm
just you know I'm I'm allowed to do what
I want to myself I'm not hurting anybody
I'm just drunk you know but that episode
really sort of punctuated you know the
fact that there are other people
involved and in particular like young
children on a very important day which I
think elevates the emotional kind of
impact of something like that but you
know I related to related to the
emotions completely and and I related to
the kind of you know roller coaster ride
of saying yeah I got to get my life
together it's time to get sober and then
just not being able to do it or that
memory so quickly fading and then you're
back to doing what you're always doing
and how long it took before you know I
was really able to get to that place to
really surrender and be willing to
accept help and do the work but you know
my lowest moment was a year and a half
before I got sober you know and if I was
writing the narrative you know in the
movie script that would have been the
moment you know but that's not the way
it works you know that's not the way it
works it did you're ready when you're
ready and it doesn't always make sense
and it's not always logical and then you
know absolutely right and and then
there's that other aspect to that I
think like a lot of my friends who who
haven't dealt with addiction in their
own lives I think that you know my
sobriety date was August 5th in 2005 and
that they think that maybe if it would
have been that day it would have been
August 10th or maybe in September but I
wasn't you know that everything was
pushing towards that point but you know
the reality is that if I wouldn't have
jumped off then I could still be there
man you might be drinking now
yeah or you might be dead
yeah it's those little cracks in the
door those precious moments where you
have just the slightest sliver of
willingness you know but if you don't
act on that Bend who knows if that ever
you're ever blessed with that yeah
opportunity again you know it really is
a precious thing the other thing that I
thought was really impactful was this
idea that you know the alcoholic is
always trying to solve the problem with
their mind but they're not aware that
their mind is is being poisoned by
chemicals right so your perception of
the world is altered and you're trying
to solve a problem from you know from a
place that's not healthy you know but
you don't have the objectivity to see
that because everything you're
processing everything that you're taking
in through your eyes and your ears is
going through this machine that is
broken yeah right and it and and so it's
all it's impossible to have any
objectivity on the reality of your
situation which makes it all the more
crucial like you know and recover you to
you hear about surrender you hear about
that willingness to ask for help and you
know without the intervention of a third
party to kind of come into that equation
it's extremely difficult it's it's like
a miracle that anybody ever gets sober
yeah absolutely like you you abusing
your brain over and over again and
killing your brain cells and then trying
to use your your warped brain to to
convince yourself to not keep drinking
it's yeah I it is an absolute miracle
and and we all know those of us that
have made it out that we got lucky you
know we just I don't know why but why it
happened on that day but it did and and
you know along with that comes a huge
sense of gratitude you know and a huge
sense of of just you know the wildermann
you know I mean I you look at and you're
like I don't know how I ever III don't
know how ever got that low and I don't
know how the hell I ever got out mm-hmm
the other thing that I loved was how you
describe sleep and the lack thereof and
I don't hear that really discussed that
often but for me like I can remember so
vividly like I never just
either I passed out or I was tossing and
turning with bed spins and throwing up
or or you know trying to go a couple
days without drinking and the sleepless
nights that accompany that or some of
the most painful nights I've ever had
like the hallucinations and this the you
know the sweating and the sheets and and
just never ever being able to just get a
legitimate night of sleep without being
altered yeah there comes this like crazy
time warp right where you you're you you
feel like you don't have enough time to
adequately abuse and and then worship
you're drugged and you you don't ever
just retire for the evening you just run
out of time and or or your body just
shuts you down before before you get to
wherever it is you're searching for and
yeah it's it's like you said that
there's no sleep there's no like okay
the nights over and now I'm having my
fill and I'm gonna you know just going
to sleep when I watch movies and TV and
I see people like drinking and then they
just go home and go to bed how does that
work yeah you're out there and they get
home at 2:00 a.m. and go to bed yeah
yeah yeah I don't understand how that
works at all like either I have to drink
enough until I completely black out to
go to sleep I would the last thing I
would do no matter if it was three
o'clock in the morning or what time it
was and how much I had to drink is I
would pour I would take like a rocks
glass or a juice glass and and just fill
it full of 90-proof something and carry
it up to bed with me and I'm not gonna
feel any benefit or effect of that it
was more of a possession thing I just
needed to have it with me and and half
the time I didn't even drink it I'd go
and set it down in the nightstand next
to me and and I could sleep because I
knew it was there but it was non-stop
drink until the moment that
consciousness left and mm-hmm I was so
aware of and I talked about in the book
of that first time when I just slept
right it's a miracle
yeah like when you're like oh my god I
have never done this yeah I was like
twelve I didn't know what this was yeah
yeah that was very palpable the way you
described that I mean when you
go out and like yesterday when you talk
to people or you know you kind of
interact with people that have read the
book you know normal people not not
alcoholics not addicts I mean what is
their reaction to reading you know the
kind of truncal log aspect of the book
you know it's it's a mixed bag but I
think you know it's the one thing I hear
a lot is I'm glad you're still alive
mm-hmm you know and and it's it's an
interesting thing to hear from people
especially people that don't know you
and I've never met you and and it's it's
it's quite common and it just drives
home that point of you know looking from
the outside and how destructive and how
how terrible that behavior was and I
think one of the most surprising things
that that's come out of this you know I
I kind of expected that
I'm just very much the same way when I
read your book I knew where you were you
know and in it in a trigger that those
emotions in me and I could feel like the
weight of the glass you were holding or
the thoughts that you were thinking I
expected the book to to reach other
people who'd been in similar
circumstances but what I haven't
expected or didn't expect was some of
the family members and I had a lady I
would recently ran a road marathon
indent in Leadville and a lady came out
to the finish line I was waiting for me
to finish and she wanted to tell me
about her son who had just passed away
and he had a od'd on heroin and he was
26 years old and she just wanted to tell
me that the book reading it gave her
some insight as to what her son might
have been feeling and what he might have
been thinking because from the outside
and a lot of people just think it's you
know indulgent you know behavior and
it's and it is and it is it's it's
selfish and it's indulgent but you know
we could talk for hours and hours on
whether it's a disease and and all these
things that are that are such hot topics
but the bottom line is once the addicts
in he's in and it doesn't really matter
you know how you got there or what
happened but um and I had the same exact
thing happen at a gym I own a gym in
Lafayette and I had someone just show up
whose wife had
head back surgery I talk about my back
surgery book and she was prescribed a
whole trough of narcotics and she got
addicted and she overdosed and she died
and and it left her family just oxy or
was it I never asked exactly what what
what they had her on but yeah I I think
that and it's my it's it's my hope that
that it continues to go that way and it
continues offer some sort of a you know
understanding or peace for people who
who are trying to figure out why why I
loved one is is so lost and so so much
struggling yeah I think it accomplishes
that I mean you did a very deft job of
describing the powerlessness and the
desperation the desire to change but you
know the the you know the inability to
and and the shame that accompanies that
because I think if you if you don't you
know if you haven't had a close
encounter with somebody who's struggling
with this disease or condition however
you want to qualify it it's it is easy
to go like why can't they just snap out
of it like what's I don't get it
you know just stop but it's so much more
complicated than that and and you really
painted this
you know pastiche of the emotional
landscape that that accompanies it and
it was it was painful to read but I also
I'm like yeah I'm right there with you
you know but I remember very very
vividly going to see that movie leaving
Las Vegas with a buddy of mine and I'm
just watching Nicolas Cage do his thing
and I'm like yeah man
let's do it like looks like a good time
to me like I'm like yep I do that too
yeah I could see yeah I could see why
he'd make that to sit you know like my
friend is just horrified at the whole
thing you know and I was like oh yeah
like and this was before I got sober you
know you know it was very evident like
oh I think differently you know I'm
getting the world through a different
lens
did you watch flight yeah yeah my my
friend John gaytan's wrote that book Oh
I mean wrote that script and you know
he's a friend that I know from recovery
obviously I mean he's writing that from
probably based you know on some of his
own experiences but and very very
powerful you know people think it's
about it you know an airplane crash or
don't know it this is a this is an
incredibly
story about what it's like to be an
alcoholic a story very well told
yeah I was honestly one of those people
I was I was absolutely blindsided by the
movie I went with a friend and I was
expecting you don't know about no I have
no idea and I was no I had tears
spilling out of my eyes rolling down my
cheeks the whole time I was it was it
was very emotional and I think they did
a really good job at showing that you
know it's not a matter of what you're
gonna do you know you're gonna drink
it's gonna happen it's just a matter of
whatever what are you doing at the same
time right right right
and also the way that you describe kind
of your trigger situations like that
first time you had to go to the airport
you know and what airports represented
for you I mean for me it's like hotels
are like going to a foreign city where
no one knows me you know and you're like
you know I could get away with something
here no one would know and like that
demon on your shoulder is right there
and and trying to kind of prepare for
those situations the amount of like work
you know recovery work that has to go
into getting ready to you know walk
through a scenario that you're so
programmed to drink or use and is is you
know is challenging and like just God
you know just reading you feeling you
like going into that Airport and the
guys that you're with are at the bar and
there are they're encouraging you to
turn it like so it's so brutal I
honestly have no idea how I made it for
that you know the first two weeks right
no I mean of all the times that I had
everything perfectly aligned for me to
get clean and I didn't do it you know I
had the time I had the time away from
work I had no stress at all these things
and it just didn't matter and then you
know once I finally did make the
decision everything kind of aligned to
to screw me up and knock me off track
and it just didn't matter at that point
and but that's the way it works it
reminded me of the story in the big book
where where Bill W is newly sober and he
has to go out of town and he's in this
hotel and he's so close to drinking and
he just goes to that pay phone and calls
the hospital and says do you have any
alcoholics you know that I can go talk
to all right and that saves him and he's
like if that payphone wasn't there he
was a goner you know and it's funny
because like I'm talking to two family
members and stuff who are just really
struggling and in the whole enabling
attics and stuff like that is something
that
it's just so hard and and occupies so
much in my time and talking to other
people and I'm dealing with it right now
with my own brother yeah I wanted to get
into that a little bit and you know it's
you have to be there for them and you
have to love them but um the point being
that once the alcoholic truly makes up
their mind that they're done and it's
real ain't nothing gonna stop mm-hm
you know so we have this tendency you
know the family members are like oh if I
say the wrong thing if I do the wrong
thing if I look in the wrong way it's
gonna screw it all up and the reality is
no no there's there's nothing you can do
to make him use he's gonna do that all
by himself and there's nothing you can
do to to get him better and once once he
makes up his mind he'll need support
he'll need help you'll need all these
things but nothing's gonna stop him you
know that has to come from inside so
your brother is out there still he is he
is an older older brother a younger
brother
Oh young I'm 10 years younger I have I
have three brothers and one older into
two younger and two of us have the
addiction demons chasing us around and
two of us don't go figure and so how is
you know how do you navigate that like
what is your communication like if any
like for somebody who's out there
listening who's dealing with the same
thing as a family member it's [ __ ] up
man I mean it's really hard because I
hear my own advice echoing in my ear and
I know it's right because other people
have told me it and it's just part of
that the truths of the addiction but I
feel the same thing other people feel I
want to you know help them out you know
and I want to believe you know that you
know I can send them 20 bucks and he's
not gonna buy heroin with it you know
that you know he get all those same
things but I know I know I can't and but
honestly it's it's almost like you would
think that being an addict would give
you a certain amount of insight and
helping another addict and that's true
but really it's it's almost unrelated I
feel like what I'm going through as a
family member trying to help my brother
is almost entirely unrelated to what I
went through as an addict myself it
allows me a window to understand what
he's thinking and to have some empathy
but it's it's such a difficult
experience and and it's it's up there
with one of the toughest things I've
ever gone through in my entire life
mm-hmm yeah well that's interesting that
you say that because the cornerstone of
recovery is one alcoholic talking to
another and certainly you've endured
enough to be able to have you know
common ground with your brother to have
that dialogue but what you can't do is
gift him with the willingness that's
required for him to even listen to you
let alone take action on anything that
you're telling him yeah and and
absolutely true and and maybe I should
be a little more clear it's like I don't
in dealing with just me and another
alcoholic it's an entirely different
dynamic in me dealing with my brother
because I'm feeling right right right
that emotional bond
yeah and that's definitely clouds it and
makes it really hard and it's given me a
whole new way to understand you know
what the family members are going
through when their loved ones because
it's it's really easy to just you know
to be in that sponsor role and say well
yeah I know what your problem is you
haven't screwed up your life enough yet
you know it's not bad enough for you yet
as soon as they give you a drink a
little right to do that with your
brother is really hard yeah and
especially when they're calling and
they're saying I'm gonna be on the
street and you know can you take me in
and and all this stuff and it ending if
I don't then and any dies or something
happens you know I have to carry that
with me yeah you can't be that
dispassionate you know sounding-board
because yeah you're dealing with other
people at enormous length you're like
here's what you do do it or don't I'm
not attached to it right this here's a
solution and then you you're not
thinking about it the rest of the day
yeah and it's been a process cuz that's
kind of the way it's had to go and so
our relationship isn't real good right
now you know but I was just telling my
mom that you know he's he's got a he's
got to be the architect of his own
recovery and um when that happens
there's nothing we won't do to help him
but I can't tell him out I mean I can
tell him how I did it I can share with
him how I did it I can tell him what I
thought what I felt and pointed in the
right direction but ultimately you know
he's the truth comes from within right
it's it's not something we find from the
outside and bring into
Our Lives it's it's something that was
always there that we just kind of
discover yeah and I think that it's
important for family members out there
who are we're dealing with this to
understand that that's very different
from trying to control a family member
into getting sober to get you off their
back right that's not willingness that's
a temporary band-aid that will not hold
ultimately
I mean there's of course there's the the
occasion where you know you do an
intervention and somebody but grudgingly
goes into rehab and then they get it
when they're in there but the more
typical case is you know it doesn't
stick because they're not ready because
it's not being driven by their own
desire it's being driven by the fear and
the love of family members who are
desperate yeah yeah so it's complicated
it's hard man it is what I mean we're
crazy creatures so what was that moment
in August that tipped the scale for you
you know um it was just I think it was
we kind of talked about before you know
alarm bells you know I kind of was a
where of each time my my drinking in my
my use was going to a new level of
destruction and and that morning there
was just something really heavy about it
and I think that I think that that was
going to be a significant day for me one
way or the other
and I think I was gonna either entirely
give up and just go go about the process
of ending it
you know maybe slowly maybe quickly or I
was gonna stand up and start to fight
and and I just felt like I had that with
that one one one shot that one little
glimpse and and I just jumped on before
I could think about it I've related it
to jumping out of a car you know like I
was driving in a car and I thought I was
driving the car and taking it to all
these nice places and one day I realized
I was in the passenger side and I had no
controller where the car was going and I
kind of hung out there for a while too
and it's like okay well I'll just see
where this thing's going and then that
that day I just opened the door and I
jumped out and before I could even think
about it like all the times I tried to
you know wrap it into this perfect thing
that made sense and you know wrestle
every demon out into a perfectly you
know understandable thing and it never
worked obviously right I had to trust
the process and you know it's kind of
just like talking about running a
hundred miles or something like that you
can't get to that place where you're
doing some run and trying to convince
yourself why it's a good idea because
it's not right you guys got a run and
that's that's what I did with the
recovery I just I just took the moment
and kept moving forward and right and
and the you know what you learn in
recovery is that you're always in the
passenger seat ultimately and it's it's
when you think that you're in the
driver's seat or you try to take the
wheel that you end up veering off into
the wrong direction and that's a that's
a you know kind of an ephemeral idea
that we could spend hours talking about
but but just that's part of the
surrender of realizing like not only am
I not in control like there are very few
things that I actually can control that
one of them is whether I drink or not
today right now most things you know are
pretty much beyond my reach yeah and
it's interesting that that the day that
you had that moment was not you know
after a car wreck or being put in jail I
mean it was similar with me like it was
a really uneventful morning like in
terms of like events that had happened
to me you know nothing you know I was
hungover but it wasn't on the heels of
anything super traumatic but there was
just it was different you know I woke up
and I was like I'm gonna die I'm ready
yeah like I'm ready or or or yeah
there's no turning back yeah you know it
was very inexplicable it wasn't you know
unicorns and rainbows and angels but you
know I still would qualify it as you
know a spiritual experience no doubt
because it was it came out of nowhere it
wasn't it wasn't triggered by any
particular event you know it was
triggered by the accumulation of many
years and terrible things but that
little gift of willingness just sort of
materialized it's funny because I I
asked for help that day and I probably
asked for help before but it was always
just some sort of exercise at melodrama
you know and and and and wanting to be
pitied more than anything
alcoholics are good at that oh yeah but
I meant it I meant at that time I felt
that the realness that I was not able to
do this anymore
and I was totally powerless you know I
was I was in over my head I was get my
ass kicked and it was gonna get any
better and and and I felt myself given
up I thought that was that I think that
was the most scary thing is that I felt
myself like I always kind of had a
little bit of fight you know I'm gonna
figure this out one day and you know
he's had a vision that you know there
would be a big intervention and they
send me off to rehab and I'd come back
and everything would be great you know
and but I felt I all of that was gone
you know I didn't even have any any
visions of getting better anymore and I
didn't like that feeling I didn't like
the idea of giving up but you had never
been to an a a meeting before it wasn't
like you'd kind of made fits and starts
or tried oh no i bent a lot oh yeah yeah
in fact um usually what would happen is
I would there would be one of those
those bad days like that should be your
bottom right now I'd wake up and not
remember where my car was and and you
know just hassle it's so bad that's but
or like that the time I talked about in
the book where I was vomiting out of my
truck window driving home yeah that
should have been that should have been
my last day you know I should've said oh
[ __ ] I didn't kill anybody today let's
that's good let's jump off this roller
coaster now but um I would have one of
those mornings and I would and I would
wake up and I'd go to AAA that night and
I'd go see I knew it I don't have a
problem I don't have anything in common
with any of these people you know these
are the guys at the problem and I would
it was like an affirmation or an excuse
to go drink some more mm-hmm and I
briefly do talk about in there where I
talked about the fight the time I really
did go to a meeting and I found what I
did have in common with all those guys
which was you know alcohol obviously
namely it was it was the same experience
we talking about with sleep it's like
how could you do something over and over
again and never experience it mm-hmm and
I've been to probably 15 or 20 AAA
meetings and they just never meant
anything to me and I mean I think I
tried to do the 90 and 90 like five or
six different we did oh yeah I think I
made three or four days and then
like I own a company I was court-ordered
so I did it for that reason
and I was just - yeah it was okay and I
was well-intentioned when I went I was
gonna get sober you know but then it
just I was kind of a tourist like I
intellectualized the whole thing yeah I
get it I understand like I'm not gonna
do all this writing stuff down I don't
need to like I can make that list in my
head done that yeah I've done that on to
the next thing like I've solved this
problem and and of course that didn't
work you know you have to have your you
know you got to go through all those
experiments I think yeah and I think
people you know a lot of people out
there don't they don't know that they
don't know how nonlinear the the journey
to recovery is for you know 99% of the
people that are sober out there they
think oh they go to rehab and they're
fine or they go to AAA and everything
changes or a therapist or whatever you
know version it is but it's usually you
know a lot of you know ups and downs and
relapses and you know people are always
you know surprised when somebody
relapses but that's the natural state of
the alcoholic the miracle is that all
those days that they didn't drink
you know there's they're like they're
wired to drink you know we're wired to
drink so every day that you don't is the
gift absolutely and I said nine years
and says a good starts amazing Congrats
a good start yeah that's fantastic
congratulations very cool so let's talk
about the weight thing yeah I mean you
got fat as fat as hell man 320 pounds
320 yeah yeah and I I can't I mean
looking at you now it's really hard to
picture that I mean I saw the pictures
in the book but you know you were a big
boy yes I was ultra before I knew it had
anything to with running man eating
drinking whatever and it's funny because
I have people say to me you know isn't
all that running bad for your knees and
I always say you know waiting in line
for my third Big Mac waiting 320 pounds
was bad for my knee
but yeah I am know food was the same
thing you know I mean the process was
was pretty much identical you know
between what was going on with my weight
and what was going on with my drinking
yeah I didn't think about food is
anything other than making me feel good
you know that's what it was for I didn't
and even though I knew better it's some
intellectually I knew better I mean I
could I could have written it out for
you and told you exactly how all this
stuff works but it didn't matter because
that's not how I saw food and and it's
funny because I talked a little bit
about there and that that I had this
this concept of food and who was thin
and who was fat and I had it all of
course figured out I had everything
figured out exactly how everything
worked right but let me tell you how I
would see you having at 320 pounds right
well you know that's interesting because
I remember telling my dad and you know
how it works like your family members
they want to let you off the hook right
they don't want you know a lot of times
you know for the the high bottom errs if
you will the ones that didn't end up on
the street mm-hmm you know um especially
if you had a level of success at some
point in your life your family wants to
believe they want to let you off the
hook and they don't want to think you
have a problem and you drink too much
obviously you need to stop that but
there's nothing wrong with you you know
that because then it becomes a
reflection of them yeah yeah but I told
my dad once I was like you know I used
to have this this concept of like well
yeah I'm overweight and yeah I drink too
much but other than that I got life
figured out right and I'm like I
realized the stupidity and the insanity
of that now you know and I like to say
you know I wasn't overweight I wasn't an
alcoholic I was broken I was a broken
human being the the food the alcohol
that was a symptom you know I I didn't
know how to live life at all had no idea
how to live life had no idea how to be
happy I had no idea how to sit and just
be still and and the the food and the
drugs and the alcohol was just something
I could do in the meantime because I
couldn't be still mm-hmm yeah that's the
other thing that that that I think a lot
of people aren't really fully in touch
with that that alcohol is the solution
for the alcohol I can tell it's the
problem
and the alcohol and the effects of
alcohol on the alcoholic are a
symptomatic you know manifestation of a
disease that's really kind of a
spiritual malady it's like there's
something wrong with this person
drinking alcohol or taking drugs solves
that temporarily until it stops working
and the drive to use is is the kind of
confused path you know of the diseased
individual to solve this problem because
they don't have any other answer and
recovery is about you know blazing this
frightening trail of trying to repair
this broken soul you know that's what it
that's what it really is and and you
know the the running and the journey
that you've been on I mean those are
kind of outward manifestations of this
path towards healing this path towards
wholeness this path towards
self-knowledge self understanding of of
putting those pieces back together yeah
yeah undoubtedly and you know and that's
what I see I mean I'm sure a lot of
people are like well the running you
just transferred all your addiction of
winning yeah you know so so many times I
have people in recovery who have become
ultra athlete so I have to ask the
question I had charlie angle on we
talked about you know okay it's gonna
come up so I'm interested everybody has
a different answer to the question so
how do you did I trade addictions yeah
that one yeah that one you know I get
that one that's this the one I get
that's the second most popular or the
first one is where to eat your protein
anyway you know first of all as you know
addiction has a huge destructive
component to it you know you can't be
addicted to loving your children you
can't be addicted to you know trying to
be more spiritual in your life you can't
be addicted anything that is overall in
improving the quality of your life and
making a better human being
can you be addicted to running sure I
think that's that point is when it when
it transfers over you know is when isn't
becoming destructive when are you
engaging in the behavior compulsively
despite all these negative consequences
I tried to switch addictions
million times in fact it was my
preferred method of trying to find
sobriety right I'd go you know what I'm
gonna become an outdoorsman you know and
I'm gonna give up drinking and I'm just
gonna go fly-fishing and I'm gonna go
camping and I'm gonna go to Alaska or
I'm gonna go to the gym and I'm gonna I
tried working out and all that stuff I
was moving cities pulling a geographic I
tried running I tried to switch my
addictions to running and I've always
kind of wanted to be that runner person
you know I just kind of was appealing to
me for whatever reason but as you know
that was that was just changing the
symptoms I may as well been trying to
switch from beer to wine or from you
know whiskey tinnitus cigarettes I mean
it just didn't matter it wasn't gonna
work that way when I finally addressed
the spiritual problems what was causing
me to live this way and once I had to
tackle some of those issues I had this
tremendous amount of mental energy and
time available to me that I could have
chosen to do anything with I could have
chosen to write music or poetry or go
camping or go running and that's what I
chose but it was very much after the
fact and that's the only way it would
have ever lasted for me mm-hmm
because I could go to the gym you know
how many times have I sat on a piece of
equipment at the gym reeking of alcohol
you know and still smell like big macs
cuz I vomited when I woke up in the
morning and and that's that's real and
that wasn't gonna work yeah I have to
remain diligent in my sobriety to
remember that training is not the same
thing as as attending to my sobriety
like going out and riding my bike and
running no matter how long that run is
that does not take the place of actually
working a program of recovery because
that's what I forget and I mean I think
I'm fine now like and now is I go get my
meditation when I'm running like no
that's that's not that's not it that is
not the solution
the minute I start to think about that
that is when I start to regress back and
move towards that relapse start feeling
sorry yeah you know running triathlon
all these things they can be you know
they can become additions you hear about
the the
iron man widow she more like you know
when it starts to be this thing that
someone escapes into because they're not
happy with their life or their avoiding
other things in their life then I think
you have to have you know hard
discussion about what the addictive
aspect of it is or what it is that
you're running away from but but as
Mishka Shu Bali said on the podcast he's
like running is hard drinking is easy
yeah that's that's professor like I
don't want to get out of bed and go run
you know but I always want to go to the
bar right and so I think that's
something to think about as well but I
think running is really this platform of
self-discovery you know and that's
that's what I found and and from reading
a book I mean that's clearly I think you
know I gather that that's your approach
to it it is very much so and I also you
know I think that we were talking
earlier about you know if that that
feeling of being lucky you know then
that why was that moment the moment and
once we arrive at that moment and once I
was there and and I put forth this this
journey of figuring out who I was and
and and trying to trust the process and
allow myself some time to heal while I
was trying to figure these things out it
took a tremendous amount of faith and
discipline and Trust and all these other
things that fit into running nicely and
you know even when I'm in a 100-mile
race you know and there's always gonna
be a moment for me I hear other people
say ah I never wanted to quit never it
was like well good for you man cuz when
I'm out there I want to quit all the
time and to be able to access that place
where everything is uncomfortable
everything sucks and there's an easy way
out and you don't take it is very
valuable and it brings me back to that
place and my early days of sobriety and
it actually gives me that feeling that
you know I'm gonna be okay as long as I
can continue to identify those things
and myself and realize that I'm not I'm
not just a victim of the moment that
right there is a choice in the moment
what do you think it is about discomfort
or or you know that willingness to you
know go beyond
the self imagined limits of your
capabilities that is so important to
this idea or this feeling of being alive
you know I can answer it for me you know
and I think that discomfort in the is a
huge part of the Attucks problem is that
you know lice can be uncomfortable just
a normal living of life is uncomfortable
we do all kinds of things we don't want
to do you know whether it's following up
with customer calls or you know doing
things that's part of life and the
addict has nothing to do with that right
I'm not gonna be uncomfortable in my
life there's no such thing I'm gonna use
if I'm uncomfortable I'm gonna use if I
have a second that's you know that's
available to me and so I think being in
that uncomfortable place is a thing that
most people are okay with and addicts
aren't so I think that for me it appeals
to me in that place that that to be not
just to be able to deal with discomfort
but to deal with it on a big level you
know is is empowering in a way and it's
an affirmation of of life and of
recovery and and of sobriety so yeah
well put you know I think that that
being ultra sensitive you can use the
word ultra in every context I know I'm
sorry I yeah I think in general addicts
and alcoholics tend to be people that
that not everybody but I think it's fair
to make a generalization that they tend
to be sensitive people and you know when
you're talking about when you were kid
and being kind of ultra said it again
you know compassionate towards some
other kid that you thought was having a
hard time that heightens everything
right so as you grow older that becomes
more painful or more difficult to bear
and then it's the easy choice to use to
numb that and then you get sober and
suddenly you're just your emotions are
charging you know firing in all
different directions and you have no
skills for how to manage that and you
honestly think that these emotional
impulses that you're experiencing are
going to kill you
it feels like you're gonna die no that's
perfect absolutely and so the process of
getting sober and recovering is learning
how to manage your emotions because your
coping mechanism gets shut off when you
start your drinking career or you're
using career and so you've got you know
whenever you started your you know
career at 13 whatever it is and until
you know 33 right 33 so you're a 33 year
old man and you have the emotional
maturity of a 13 year old yeah and then
and you're in the world right and you
have responsibilities and you know that
leads to panic attacks and freak outs
and all sorts of things that you know
without really having a solid foundation
for sobriety you're gonna return using
ultimately yeah I mean that's the
perfect analogy and you know we all see
those you know kids that can't cope and
they're throwing tantrums and they're
doing all this and that's that's like
our behavior that's right there that's
the stereotypical addict I can't have it
my way you know I'm gonna freak out and
take everybody down with me yeah what I
always hear is emotions are just
emotions man you can feel them and they
change and you'll get to the other side
of it they will not kill you like so I
have to think like it's not gonna kill
me all right kill me you know in some
sense the pain of running and ultra is
much more tolerable than some of the
emotional pain that that I've
experienced yeah physical pain is is a
lot easier to deal with and and I think
that's I think that's ultimately what
happens in in ultra is that you have to
learn to divide physical pain from
mental pain and or emotional pain
because you have what's going on in your
legs which is actually kind of the
smallest part of it it's it's the
emotion and the meaning your minds
putting into that and and telling you
hey this could all be over really quick
you're probably injured you need to sit
down and mm-hmm you need to go on this
was a bad idea you know and being able
to separate those exactly like what you
said it's okay you're okay
mm-hmm you know just slow it down
breathe a second and it's gonna be all
right it emotions
there's no such thing as an
inappropriate emotion it's just
inappropriate times to feel them I think
that's the big thing for me is I never
had the emotion in the occasion aligned
to be appropriate right I'm experiencing
anger here well being able to create
that dividing line between physical pain
and emotional pain you know particularly
in the context of sport or running
running an ultramarathon I mean that's
that's the keys to the kingdom you know
when you're talking about a hundred mile
run it's it's it's not the physical
that's gonna bury you it's it's the
mental like I mean as David Goggins
famously said when you think you're done
you've only accomplished about 40
percent of what you're truly capable of
so it's all about your mental state your
emotional state you know your spiritual
connection and whatever form that takes
that is either gonna carry you across
that finish line to some kind of
triumphant victory or just bury you yeah
my take on the the cliche the yogi ISM
about how much of it is mental and how
much of it is physical and you know
there's there's a thousand them out
there mine is um it's all mental even
the physical take it one further okay
it's all spiritual alright there you go
I like that you know because it's not
supposed to be anything right well it's
like look I'm gonna come off like a
woowoo New Age guy but the truth is like
it's all a spiritual journey you know
all the things that I'm doing the things
that you're doing we're all born that
day that you made that decision to get
sober and get in the passenger seat and
it's taking you on this remarkable
amazing journey some of which you know
you've played a small part through the
actions that you've taken but on some
level you know your this is your this is
your path man you know this is you this
is this is your divinely inspired
journey that you're on and it's a
beautiful thing to see so when people
say to me oh you know what what do you
think is your strength and your weakness
and you know how do you do these things
and all that I'm like dude I have no
idea I mean I can give the flip answer
you know I can give the five reat things
you can think it
I can do all that but I'm like the real
truth like the honest truth is I don't
know because it's about it was it all
began when I threw my arms up and said I
don't know what I'm doing yeah your
strike your weakest moment was your
strongest moment yeah mm-hmm and I think
that that's tough especially for guys
you know we're you know we're not reared
to say I don't know or to say I need
help or will you help me or you know I'm
lost these are not the characteristics
of the successful man in Western culture
no doubt man I mean it was an absolute
the biggest obstacle that I faced in
trying to what I called you know get
sober cuz you know there's there's as
you know there's such a big difference
between sobriety and recovery and and
and not using you know not using is not
even remotely related to being sober you
know you're just not using anymore
and that's where I was is like I was
almost wit I was willing to kind of do
the work if someone would have given me
you know what here's what you need to do
I think I was willing to try to do that
and make it happen but what I wasn't
willing to do was admit that I wasn't
capable of doing the work I'm a man I
can take care of this you know I'll do
this I'll fix this and and I I could
never get to the first step because that
per that was the problem
right there right so you can get to that
place where you will literally do
anything and you will take direction
from somebody even if you think that
person is crazy or has no business
telling you what to do because don't you
know who I think I am you know until you
can get over that and really destroy the
ego to get to that place you know it
takes it takes destroying the ego to get
to that place where you can actually
grow and if that's completely
counterintuitive but yeah it's the
greatest feeling when you can finally
let go of that yeah so and I think
there's a lesson in there you know to
you know competing and stuff like that
is that is giving over that control even
when you get to a place where you want
to be competitive I have to accept any
possibility in a race I'm gonna accept
the two extremes right I could win
or I could not finish and once I'm okay
with either scenario then I can just run
I can just be in the moment wrong you're
not attached yeah yeah that's freedom
yeah that's freedom all right 320 pounds
okay yeah I used to use a lot more soap
a lot more of a lot of things
yeah 320 pounds I mean the only other
person I've had on the podcast who who
is you know pushing the scale at that
level was Josh Lou Johnny and it was
fascinating to hear his story of how he
finally kind of came to grips with it
and and got on top of it and and I saw
similarities in your story and one of
the things that that really struck me
actually highlighted it you said
changing your body and losing weight
long-term is not about willpower and you
go on and then you say you have to
change the way you think and change the
way you perceive the world right so it's
not about a diet or some kind of
short-term goal it has to do with like
doing the inside work to change your
entire kind of orientation about how
you're interacting with the environment
around you yeah absolutely
yeah and we started talking about that
earlier when I was like I used to have
this weird perception of food and and
what people are and I would think you
know like I would see some you know fit
looking person and they're you know
eating a salad or something and they're
eating some really healthy and I go what
the hell are you doing man you're you're
thin and fit you can eat whatever you
want why aren't you eating like totally
screwed up in my head I wasn't thinking
wow he that person is healthy and
vibrant looking because they eat well I
thought that's just who they are mmm and
it has nothing you know that was almost
a byproduct of it and I certainly yeah
like if I look like that I'd eat a Big
Mac that's like that's the same that's
like saying if I wasn't an alcoholic I
get drunk every night so I mean so much
of it is image right and how we see
ourselves and and I didn't see myself as
someone who needed to lose weight at
that point I saw myself as a fat person
and I was always gonna be a fat person
and if if I was going to not be a fat
person I had to figure out a way to
trick my body you know or trick the
universe and trick the world into
getting me skinny you know and I think
that what is it let's sit there for a
minute what is it what is it like to be
that heavy
you know just the day-in day-out like
you know shopping for pants and getting
a belt and sitting on an airplane and
standing in line like just the simple
things of navigating a typical day yeah
absolutely the airplanes a big one
because I used to you know I was
traveling a lot and I would get on a
plane and I would walk down the aisle
and I could see everybody looking at me
and they were just going oh [ __ ] no
please please no no no and then you know
someone would lose the lottery and I'd
plop down next to them and you know you
got extra like to have that little like
thing for the seat belt with the
extender on it you know I I didn't ever
I never needed that but you know I would
definitely spillover into the chair next
to me you know and that person would
have to twist sideways a little bit I
was not the type of person who could lit
something like that go I would have to
joke about it you know so I would I
would start the conversation right I'm
go home you know what did you do in your
past life you know sorry you lost the
lottery today and you know if you'd
waited ten more minutes you'd have got a
different seat on the plane you know you
shouldn't be in such a hurry you know
that kind of stuff but but all of that
is just like defense reaffirming this
like sense that you're a piece of [ __ ]
absolutely mm-hmm absolutely and I I
hear that from people all the time they
go you know I I'm I'm I'm just this way
and I'm happy and and you know I I can't
presume to know exactly what another
human being is is really feeling but I
can say well I used to say that too and
and it wasn't true it wasn't honest you
know I wasn't happy with with how I
loved I would joke about it I would talk
about it but I wasn't happy it's a
defense mechanism absolutely and you
know when I first started losing weight
you know my I was wearing size 50 pants
with a 30 inch inseam and that's that's
as big as it got for me I had the
stretchy waist pants you know I had to
have the little elastic bands in him and
you know I sighs was became much
more of a concern than fashion you know
just finding things that fit was you
know hard to do so if I could find
something fit that I actually that fit
and I'd like the way look that was a
bonus you know so you know kind of
looking like you eventually end up
looking like a clown no matter why cuz
you hear like a flannel shirt and plaid
pants and you know because that's all
you can find in your size so I noticed
when I lost the weight I went and played
golf and I hadn't played in a long time
and it was the most strange sensation
because when I went to line up a putt
my hands were right up close to my body
and it felt so uh because my hands were
way out here past my belly before when I
was when I was putting and change it
actually changed my my entire golf swing
too because I wasn't of course licensed
ball was much better but I digress
I would imagine and and at the time you
know what's it look like
McDonald's Hardee's Burger King Pizza
Hut what's what's the daily routine you
know yeah fast food lots of fast food um
I would towards a you know my my weight
gain in food consumption was really
getting worse in the same way that my
drinking was you know it was progressing
you know I and towards the end I was
eating fast food three or four times a
day and I would go to McDonald's and I'd
get to sausage mikeg with biscuits
sausage biscuits with a and cheese and
hash browns and of course a diet coke
and then I've since the way it is don't
want to spike that blood sure yeah I
know that extra 200 calories but you
know and then and then in the the
afternoon I'd go to you mentioned Arby's
I'd go there a lot but I'd always get
the you know those potato cake things
they have and I'd get like four of those
mmm you know to go along with whatever
sandwich I had and and then that would
usually be it because then I'd start
drinking and right and then the usually
last meal the day came late you know
where it was just you know just
gluttonous I mean just you know just I'd
go get a double quarter-pounder which is
a fillet of fish french fries and those
french fries would come back the next
day like in whole
french-fry pieces like not even the way
the way that would work for me is I you
know I didn't want to eat because that
would interfere with the buzz yes so I
would go as long as I could without
eating when I was drinking because I
didn't want that in my stomach because
that would make me feel tired or it
would you know take longer to get drunk
and inevitably at the end of the night
you're starving yep so you do this
massive binge and I would wake up you
know I just wake up with you know pizza
box you open on my bed and like Big Mac
wrappers and my sheets and just is just
the worst terrible you can say almost
smell it oh yeah it's had really
pathetic but that's why they invented
like hundred proof snobs so this year
your stomach was really full and it's
dessert like it's peppermint maybe I
should go back so all right so so you're
getting sober and you're realizing like
I got out now this is the next thing
that I have to address and and you take
a very interesting kind of approach I
mean first you try all these diets
Mediterranean diets and whatever it is
all of them and then you kind of you
know flick the switch and say I'm gonna
put my scientific hat on because you his
background and approach it from a
different perspective so you know walk
me through that yeah so the main thing I
was cognizant of was behaviorally that
whatever the process I used to get me to
where I wanted to be had to be
sustainable you know and I knew I was
never gonna be able to eat all protein
for the rest of my life
you know or I was never gonna be able to
restrict my calories for the rest of my
life and you cuz you'd lost weight and
gain impact you've done the yo-yo thing
bunch of time I lost 50 pounds at least
eight or nine times you know and and I'd
always do it on some crazy you know diet
and and usually it would you know come
undone because number one I didn't want
to just you know keep eating that way
and number two I wasn't drinking and
that wasn't gonna last very long mmm you
know so yeah I figured um I had to
figure out a way to have a healthy
relationship with food and I had to eat
and that was really difficult because I
told
linked up losing weight with not eating
obviously or or just eating or eating in
some extreme way to trick my body like
the the Atkins thing is 100% protein is
what I use like blast five or six times
right you know and and it's funny
because it's just very effective at
losing weight but you know people have a
lot have a hard time staying on it oh
absolutely and I talked a lot about
weight loss now and whenever I have a
group in front of me I say how many how
many people have been on a successful
diet and people raise their hands and
I'm like good keep it up there so your
idea of a successful diet of gaining
weight losing weight gaining weight
losing weight like because if it's not
you should put your hand down right so I
mean but it's just the word diet alone
sort of infers temporary yes absolutely
yeah so I changed the way that that I
ate and you know the glycemic index to
me made a lot of sense just because I
knew that there is a way that food was
affecting my body outside of just
calories and in calories out I knew
there was something bigger in play and
you know we used to I think you know in
in 50 hundred years ago whatever or
longer that the way that you would be
overweight is is by being gluttonous
right I mean you had to just eat all the
time and certainly I was guilty of that
but it seemed like there was so much
more in play now with it with the types
of foods that we have that are that are
causing you know us to crave things that
we wouldn't normally crave and and that
we're just kind of in this Mis cycle you
know this this that our biology wasn't
working for us we were kind of working
it against us and so I became a real
student of the glycemic index and and
how my blood sugar was was affected and
and I became an absolute stickler on it
and I mean I wouldn't have anything with
sugar in it at all and just to paint the
complete picture I mean when you were
tipping the scales at 320 not only were
you overweight you got a heart condition
you had extremely high blood pressure
and you had been diagnosed with diabetes
right yeah this is not just fat guy this
is like sick fat guy yeah I know when
when they took my the last time I was at
the doctor and in my blood
sure was so high and I wish I could
remember the numbers I have to have to
go back and get him but there was a two
in there and uh but they didn't want me
to leave the the doctor's office I mean
they're like you're going to have a
stroke I'm not telling you you might
have a stroke you are going to have a
stroke you know it could be in three
minutes no you need to be on medication
you need to be on now and I didn't like
that you know so I never and my
reasoning was I never went on on
medication because I had read that
medication is unhealthy blood pressure
medication and that shit'll kill you
your breathe I'm still perceiving the
world through a warped brain yeah
absolutely so I of course I'm like the
smart thing would have been I'm on that
medication right now I'm gonna work my
way off it but let's not have a stroke
in three minutes yeah I was not capable
of the smart thing in fact I had the
code I was I was meeting my friend at
the bar and that's fact I had someone my
buddy Dan was waiting for me at the bar
while I was at the doctor I can't hang
out doctor's office yeah and of course I
told him to be done yeah we sat and
laughed about it and you know drank
yourself said oh my god so yeah I was
really really unhealthy
oh but yeah I became a science student
of the the glycemic index and that was
kind of the the end-all be-all for me
while I was losing lay and it was like
everything else of progression you know
that eventually led me to adopting a
plant-based diet and all that but during
those initial stages it was really no
sugar no breads no processed foods and I
just I went into it with that mentality
that my body's gonna heal you know and I
need to give it time to do that that I'm
gonna trust that this is kind of part of
the same process I was on with alcohol
that I was sick and unhealthy and as
time went by I was gonna get better and
and I'd looked at food being the same
way that I crave all these things that
are killing me
and if I just give it enough time that
that I'm not gonna crave those things
anymore and I'm gonna get to a better
place and I'm not gonna be in war with
myself the whole time
mm-hmm yeah the analogy with there's a
couple analogies with with Josh's Josh
la Johnny's message and and that is
this place that you came to that he also
came to which was I'm not doing this I'm
taking my focus off the scale I'm taking
my focus off of losing weight I'm
looking at this from a perspective of
how can I be healthy and how can I be an
athlete and there's this thing in the
book where you see where somebody says
well if you're trained for ultra
marathons who cares what you eat right
but you're saying I want to be a healthy
human being and that's very different
from I want a slimmer waistline yeah
well and I mean there's a big difference
between a slim waistline and even health
and even fitness mhm and there's there's
no shortage of people out there now who
are extremely fit but they're not
healthy you know they they eat poorly
and they have high cholesterol and they
have high blood pressures and other
things but they can run you know
five-and-a-half minute miles they don't
usually work that way
you know but usually if you're taking
that much time to train your body or
yeah you're trying to treat yourself
right but we know that they're there
they're not you know mutually exclusive
right so so you adopt this approach and
and so what happens like how long before
you know you're you get to a place where
your blood pressure starts to normalize
and the weights coming off like we walk
me through the evolution a little bit so
I I logged every workout that I've ever
had since I was started at 320 pounds
like and I have these notebooks these
little day planners where I was writing
down my my calories in there and
typically what I'd have is I was I was
eating um a carbohydrate restricted diet
but I was I just I said that I could eat
as many carbohydrates that I wanted as
long as they came from vegetables you
know and and but I wasn't having any
starches or anything like that and I
wrote down everything in the little the
little journal on each day and I was
weighing myself religiously no rice no
potatoes no no fruit I didn't really
restrict fruit but I was I was avoiding
it at times you know but if I wanted it
I needed it I had it you know because it
was on a healthy list you know what
about potatoes sweet potatoes very good
sweet potatoes I would have for sure
again I all bow down to the glycemic
index so I kind of had this this um this
pass or fail grade you know I was like I
think it was 50 if something was higher
you know than a 50 on the glice
index I wouldn't have it and if it and
if it was close to that fifty-eight
would be something I wouldn't have very
often you know and then the lower down
the spectrum they went you know
interesting and but you're still eating
meat and dairy at this I was yeah
yes absolutely and you know as as wait
does my weight started you know bouncing
around a lot you know I'd lose you know
when you've been out of shape and you're
drinking a lot and you're just living so
horribly you're gonna see a dramatic
result at first and I was no exception I
want to say I lost 40 pounds to first
month you know and one in one mile and
then it levels so that's like 80 percent
90 percent booze right right well and
and the bad decisions that come with
booze like all the late night McDonald's
and all that
yeah but interestingly actually need to
back up one quick second because for the
first couple weeks after I stopped and
maybe even 30 days after I stopped
drinking
I was eating really terribly still um I
just quit drinking and that was that was
enough yeah that was in Nigeria and in
fact in my hotel room I looked at my
refrigerator one day and I just started
laughing because it was like pop-tarts
and the little chocolate-covered
doughnuts and frosted flakes and Wonder
Bread
I bought a loaf of Wonder Bread I had a
Wonder Bread so like eight years old
quick I would just create a little sugar
you need like a little comfort yeah no I
was just broke up with your best friend
so absolutely my my abusive marriage
came to an end but I still missed my
partner mm-hmm and so then I then I kind
of I was in that place from like okay I
need to address these these things
together um but I stopped weighing
myself because I was that old attic
brain you know and I was just trying to
control that number and it wouldn't
listen to me and it kept sending me back
into that that place and you know you
know what addiction feels like and it
felt like that you know it felt like
that ugly place to me again where I was
obsessing about it and I was thinking
about it all the time and I was so I
just had to let it go on and I
eventually thought you know I mean this
for health I'm in this because I want to
live and if I ultimately can do the
things I want to do and I can look the
way I want to look and feel the way I
want to feel I don't care if that number
ever
if it stays 320 that's okay that's okay
so I started another surrender yeah yeah
absolute total complete surrender and
and it was once again very empowering to
me and it gave me a new focus and it
allowed me to put more energy into what
I was doing instead of less
and I still through the measurements on
occasionally to just make sure
everything was moving in the right
direction because there's not that
emotional component to a measurement
right if I see a movement and this is
what I try to do with people that I help
lose weight is go with the emotion of
the scale man if you if you want 4
pounds of weight loss and you get 3 it's
a failure but if your measurements go
down an eighth of an inch its success
because because there's not that
emotional part to it so and I could
obviously see my my clothes changing and
and and I was feeling better and then I
just um just kept going mm-hmm and so
how does it continue to evolve you have
this you know it's a pretty rigorous
kind of glycemic index approach and then
how did it kind of morph over time into
what you do now so I was becoming fitter
and fitter I decided was gonna run a
marathon somewhere along the way I did a
5k which was the scariest thing that
ever happened to me I'm right and this
is not an overnight thing
you know this is this is running for 15
seconds yeah because that's all you
could do and that description of the
little bump on the sidewalk that you
know elevated this sidewalk you know a
foot you know was was the big terror it
was and I could see that thing coming
man there's like an eighth of a mile
loop around the park and I could just
feel the weight of that ten foot right
it's coming like it was hope pass you
know what was it that that you think
clicked in you that said running or you
know I have this dream of running a
marathon like why
running why not I mean what was a you is
there anything specific that you think
made you gravitate towards that as this
litmus test for growth yeah yeah it
seemed impossible I mean and I really
think that was it and you know I think
that I think all human beings to a
certain extent kind of have that that
thing that will rise the
you know and I felt like if something
didn't seem impossible it didn't seem
like it was worth doing and I wanted it
to be big and I wanted it to be
meaningful you know I wanted it to be
something something worthy of creating a
whole new life and and I don't know it
was running and I I do firmly believe
that it could have been something else
you know as long as it had those same
components to it but the state the
emotional stakes had to be high very
high to get you out of bed and to really
kind of be powerful enough for you to
really restructure how you were living
your day every day yeah and and because
I had tried to do it in the past and I
couldn't it almost became this thing
where you know when I ran the first time
for 20 minutes non-stop I mean that
seemed like a really big success you
know and you know kind of you know proof
that things were going in the right
direction that I wasn't just spinning my
wheels
mm-hm even though I was running on a
treadmill so technically that was
exactly spinning my wheels so so from
that first you know 15 second run and
panting - the first marathon how long
are we talking August of 2005 to October
of 2006 mm-hmm so a little over a year a
little over a year so but that's a that
was a very focused year it was and when
you ran that first 15 seconds what were
you weighing then 3 20 20 and at your
first marathon
what were you clocking in 180 180 and it
was very interesting 20 pounds heavier
than where you ended up at badwater yeah
man it was really important to me and
you know we're all on our own journey
you know and everyone has their own
their own kind of thing they're trying
to do but for me it was really important
that I approached the marathon I wanted
to be a runner when I got there and I
wanted to run it I didn't need to run it
really fast you know but I wanted it to
be my victory lap so I wanted to achieve
all of my weight-loss goals and my
health and fitness goals along the way
mm-hmm and I didn't want it like the old
me would have just been like okay what's
the minimum amount I can do and still
get this finishers medal you know what I
mean and can I fake it can I walk it can
I get through it
and yeah because that's about saying you
did it as those two really embracing
the experience and and what it actually
means to tackle that and give it your
best go absolutely I didn't want to run
a marathon I wanted to be the type of
person that could run there mm-hmm yeah
that's that's say that again that's an
important distinction I didn't want to
run a marathon I wanted to be the type
of person who can run marathons to be a
runner yeah somebody who did a marathon
yeah yeah absolutely
that was that was a really big really
big part of the journey for me and it
kept me motivated and it kept me going
out there and I did the 5k I was when
you were a hold on all right so when
you're 320 and you have this idea that
you're gonna run a marathon I mean how
long before you said said those words
out loud to another human being it
didn't take too long so what's the
reaction you're getting oh they would
look look me up and down and yeah all
right buddy yeah okay Dave ready got
back to Arby's yeah I remember I
remember last time you said you're never
gonna drink again seriously but you know
I think insanity is an amazing tool you
just gave me that tagline for this
episode RRP episode whatever David
Clarke
I think insanity is an amazing tool it
is because it can create leverage didn't
produce anything you want right you know
and you got to be afraid of the person
it's too crazy to know better right and
so I didn't mind I was just like you
know what screw it you know
go ahead laughs you know and I went and
I had these little silicone bracelets
made up that said 26.2 and I just
thought that was like really archaic
like an obscure and and like no one
would know what it meant or anything
like and you know and and that was it is
that mysterious nobody's that number I
feel like that's the same number in that
like white oval sticker on the back of
every car they I know and I still lived
in Colorado at the time but yeah so I
decided I was runner and and I wasn't
gonna let reality it and get in the way
get in the way of that
that you redefined yourself I mean that
is you know a transformation a mental
and
emotional transformation that precedes
the physical transformation Yeah right
like you stepped into this identity
before it had been manifest and assumed
the role yeah III think that that's a
big thing and I think we we pigeonhole
ourselves and create these images of who
we are and rarely are they based in in
facts they're just emotional attachments
that we made you know somewhere along
the way and childhood we were we were
told you were the smart one or you were
the stubborn one or the fat one or
whatever it is and and it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy and it's really
important I think for human beings to be
in a place where how you view yourself
and who you are matches with what you're
doing and and I think I talked a little
bit about it in the book that we create
this conflict and and with the with the
Attic me whenever I tried to stop
drinking that was my behavior I was
trying to not drink but I knew I was a
drinker so that wasn't gonna ever last
very long you know because I was at
battle with myself and I had to look at
myself as someone who wouldn't dream of
drinking alcohol who would never consume
you know recklessly and then destroy
myself like that and once I did that and
address that that spiritual part of that
and was able to get myself to buy into
that then the behavior changed a little
more naturally but what is the process
of changing that identity saying yeah
because you're saying you know going
from knowing you're an alcoholic to
saying not saying but but believing I am
somebody that doesn't drink or I am
somebody who I am a runner I am somebody
who runs marathons like what is the
process of that because I think you know
listen the truth is most people who are
alcoholics don't get sober and most
people that weigh 320 pounds don't lose
160 pounds so what is it that was
different about you and how you know how
did you kind of create that you know
create that new path for yourself I mean
I guess I'm looking for you know I'm
looking for you to be able to articulate
the process a little bit for somebody
who's out there who's like please tell
me how you did this
yeah and and I was joking about it when
I said the insanity thing but there's
actually a modicum of truth to that and
you have to I had to drink the kool-aid
right you had to believe it yeah it's
not about like looking in the mirror and
saying you know trying to convince
yourself of something you actually don't
believe right so that meant moving
forward once I decided that I believe
that I had to only engage dr. Collins in
behaviors that supported that view of
who I was and anything that would come
up because all kinds of things would
come up to tell show me and prove to me
on a daily basis that I wasn't that
person I'd be like I've always been that
person I'm just off track now I'm
getting back to where I'm supposed to be
this was this was who I was supposed to
be all along and I screwed it up and so
I think you know there's so much
information that comes into our daily
lives and you know we can't we tend to
grab onto the things that support our
predetermined ideas right even if it's
like oh that guy's a jerk like I can do
something really nice and you're gay
yeah but that's not real he's an [ __ ]
I don't know and it's the same thing I
think with our behaviors and and there's
a big difference between being someone
who needs to lose weight and someone you
know who's a fat person and so I started
deleting all of the information that
came my way that supported that I was
supposed to be overweight that I was you
know supposed to be an addict that it
was just genetically wired into my DNA
sometime I was like [ __ ] I'm not
even gonna entertain that idea store it
throw it away
and I would shift my direction over to
something else I would you know take a
physical action like getting online and
looking up marathons and reading about
marathon training plans and and reading
about running shoes and or just go for a
run you know like there's no greater way
to prove to yourself you're a runner
than going back you know so and I would
do that and it's like everything became
an affirmation I was like okay this is
it this is this is real and and I
believe I would imagine it starts with a
little fake until you make up damn right
what would a runner do well I don't know
water would probably go running yeah a
runner would probably go on a website
and try to learn something about running
shoes yeah you have to be willing to be
a little stupid
you know and a little crazy at first and
it's hard and you'll try to talk
yourself out of it I certainly did you
know yeah there had to be those moments
where you're kidding us they're like
what are you doing yeah yeah yeah but I
just I figured you know that I wasn't a
320 pound alcoholic addict by accident
right and and it was all of the crap
that I put on myself that got me there
so is that surrender thing it was like
it's really easy for me to say I don't
have it all figured out you know I don't
know if I did I wouldn't be here so I'm
gonna say that this is this is the way
it is and and I have no proof otherwise
because I don't have anything figured
out mhm interesting and did you try to
surround yourself with a community of
people that could teach you and support
this dream or are you going lone wolf on
this um at first I was very much alone
I think the first outward action I took
into the running community was was going
to a running store in Boulder and which
could be an incredibly intimidating it
was it was really intimidating and it
was really hard i sat out in front of
the store for a long time and you know
it's like it's it was a little better
buying my shoes that you know the Sports
supports outliers yeah where you know
it's more not easier right yeah but you
know again it was like all those things
I was like you know the old me would
have just left and gone somewhere else
you know I'm gonna do things differently
now I'm gonna I'm gonna go in here and
I'm not only a real runner is gonna go
to the real running store and it's gonna
ask the real questions yeah and not only
am I gonna go in I'm gonna just tell him
who I am and why I'm here you know I'm
not even a candy-coated you know I'm
like hey you know I've lost 60 pounds
and I want to run a marathon mm-hmm you
know and as almost like daring him to to
you know laughs it's like this is it
how'd that go you know they was they
were incredibly supportive you know and
then how now I know that you know it's a
great community of people but yeah they
were incredibly supportive he asked me
questions about you know what speed does
running in and and you know how many
miles I was doing and and I shared all
of that willingly and and he was very
encouraging
mmm thought said you know hey you did a
great job and you know good for you and
that was that was important for me
because it was an affirmation that I
hadn't gotten right now before so I
think it's very he's looking at you like
you mean business he's not questioning
you yeah so it's another little like
knotch
you know and it's interesting that once
once it came full circle and you know
I'd done the marathon and then I was I
was getting involved more in the running
community and doing more group runs with
people and things like that
I never hid my story you know ever but I
didn't willingly share it and I think
you need to talk about part of the
process you know there was there was a
growing process along the way in that
first two years I was kind of fumbling
my way through my sobriety I was
fumbling my way through the weight loss
I was fumbling my way through everything
and I hadn't really put it together yet
I was certainly better than I was before
but I thought somehow if I shared where
I'd come from that people would think
less of me they wouldn't accept me as a
real runner you know so that was like
that last little bit that was that was
holding on interesting yeah and the iron
the great irony is that the story's so
powerful and it's a journey towards
willingness another level of willingness
and surrender to be vulnerable enough to
share the story yeah because I felt like
I worked to get to a certain place and I
didn't want anything to detract from it
right and I don't want people who see me
as that other guy because I work so hard
to be this new guy that's that's in the
past so so when you sit down to write
the book I would imagine you might have
been you know struggling or grappling
with a little resistance you know when
it comes to filling in the gaps and and
and really flushing out the details of
of your story I mean I know I
experienced that when I was writing my
book but I also was very aware that that
was the only thing that was gonna make
the book work was whether I was willing
to do that yeah it was definitely a test
if you will of
you know how much you're willing to put
yourself out there I mean there's so
much went into that title you know yeah
from just the crazy part of just you're
out there to putting yourself out there
too and so you know what we call people
who are still out there struggling he's
gay they're out there but it was it was
the most incredible journey of
self-discovery that I've ever been on
and I still I've been asked a couple
times if I do a little book event or
something to say you want to read
something from it and I know I can't you
know I can't and ever just times I was
literally laughing out loud while I was
writing it and other times I was just
bawling and crying and I'd have to walk
outside and pray and thank God that I
made it out you know and because when
you're when you relive something as you
know from the writing process it's I
just couldn't believe the amount of
emotion and detail that would come back
when I sat down and started to write you
start remembering stuff that you know
you forgot about or it just comes back
and technical or yeah and it's not
always welcome no no but you know there
were there were certainly times where I
was like this is just too much you know
and you know I really wasn't sure until
til probably I'm not even sure when
they'd be exact moment I was 100% sure I
was gonna actually like release it or
publish it or anything like that
I knew I had to write it for for me and
then I figure today I know my mom would
buy one you know I could imagine anyone
ought to read my crap you know but I was
like if someone does then that's just
about well when you when you make that
decision though you're like all right
you know it's it's a scary thing you
know it's a scary thing and I and I you
know when I was writing the drunk alog
part of my book listen you know I could
like yourself I could tell stories all
day long and I have a lot of you know I
have plenty of stories that are a lot
worse that are in the book but it's like
what is the purpose of this book like
you know I need to establish that this
is my past but but you also you can you
can attach your ego to those stories
like look how crazy I was you know and
it's like it's not about that now you
know it's not it's not for shock value
it's like okay I need to people need to
understand that this is the place that
I'm coming
but you know I didn't want I didn't want
to freak people out either like you can
go too far with it no doubt you have to
find that balance for me I went after
the stories that I had the most
humiliation attached to cuz they're the
ones I didn't want to share because
there's the ones you talking about the
ones that you talk about with your
buddies and they're that are kind of
kind of funny kind of you know you laugh
about them and and you know they're the
crazy Rockstar kind of stuff but you
know I didn't want like you said I want
to glamorize it and I figured you know
I'll share the room that we can be like
romanticize absolutely yeah absolutely
but sitting on a park bench and [ __ ]
yourself in LA is not that's not so
romantic yeah yeah yeah and the thing
about it though is by making that
decision to say okay it's out there I
mean that's freedom yeah you feel that
though right yeah yeah if yeah I've told
this to some friends like if you ever
want to experience true freedom you
write down every piece of [ __ ] moment
you've had and put it out there for the
world okay and you want to feel like
you're walking through Times Square
naked yeah that's what it's like yeah
but and there's such a difference
between you know telling your friends or
even a group of a hundred people some of
your personal things and actually
putting it in print mm-hmm or if people
can reread it and pick it apart and
analyze it and but I and criticize it
and criticize it and that's was my kind
of um deal with myself or whatever it's
like once the book is done and once it's
actually published it's not mine anymore
mm-hm and anything that anyone wants to
think about it want to how they want to
interpret it is up to them they bought
the book they read it they have their
right to what they feel about it it's
it's it's theirs now yeah and part of
the deal also is criticized away sure
but if one person out there reads it and
gets sober like it's all worth it or one
person out there you know changes their
diet and does something that they didn't
think that they could do then that's
that's great
yeah cuz that's what it's about they
just stop giving up on themselves and I
have no doubt that that is the impact of
this book
whether you've experienced it directly
or not yet you will how long how long is
it what did it come out it's been out
for two months now okay so brand-new
yeah it's just starting for you man you
know it's it's been more than I could
have ever imagined so far and it's just
starting and hopefully yeah yeah yeah I
mean with it comes I think a little
mantle of responsibility now because you
kind of carry this inspiration torch you
know and people are gonna look to you
and say how did you do it help me you
know help you can you can you help me
and and and you're gonna find yourself
in this position where people are gonna
be you know wanting you to God guide
them I mean have you started to
experience that you know I I have and I
mean I know your training and coaching
people and and all that so you're you're
already engaged in that professionally
but just sort of the emails will come in
and stuff like that yeah yeah and and
I'm I'm always thankful for those emails
but it is tough it is tough because you
know you don't always have the the piece
of advice that people people want you
know and I'm never gonna tell someone
what I think they want to hear some of
my whole life doing that kind of [ __ ] so
I'm just gonna let the truth like the
way you know some sometimes the truth
just demands to be said so right you
know as I write like a lot of people you
know they have these passive passive
aggressive reach out for help kind of
thing and I did it
you know I called in a a meeting one
time and I was like you know when is
your next meeting and they're like I
don't know let me find someone who knows
and this and that and that's like you
know they were just laughing their ass
off they're like this drug you know but
I think a lot of people do that they'll
reach out and they expect you to be able
to you know like make something happen
it's like I'll share with you every
corner of my soul and everything that
I've ever been through but that's all I
can do I don't have any secret pieces of
wisdom it's it's on them to actually you
know take what's in the book or what's
out there and actually implement it into
their lives and yeah that's that's the
hard piece right I mean looking back you
know
put yourself back at 320 pounds at the
end of your drinking career and and and
just imagine that you would be somebody
who had not only run bad water done all
these crazy races that you've done have
written this book you know be a source
of inspiration to other people be
actually you know coaching and training
other people I mean is that could you
have possibly imagined that no well I
don't know no no I mean where did you
you know it well what would have your
what would your dream have been like it
was the far the second see like well
yeah like where did you well you know
what were you aspiring to I wanted to
run the New York City Marathon one day
mmm I thought you know and it's funny
because like I remembered seeing the
Ironman Triathlon when I was a kid and I
couldn't quite get to the point where I
could ever see myself doing that but I
had this idea like I wonder if I could
train for it like not actually do it but
could I just train train could I just
could I just like like what a weird
thought though yeah yeah I what do you
think that's about like doing the race
would actually mean that you'd be
accountable to other people or I just
don't think that I could put it out
there I think that I saw that as a
certain type of person that could do
that and I wasn't that person but maybe
I could be the type of person who might
be able to train for anything yeah
interesting all right so you get the
marathon done and then where does the
idea of like taking it to the ultra
level start to creep into the
consciousness I read Dean's book and
actually before that even right after I
finished a marathon my my ex-wife I was
sitting there I still like still jacked
up you know walking down stairs
backwards and stuff and I don't think
I'd taken my blue Denver marathon hoodie
off and you know I think there's like 30
days before I stopped wearing that every
single day and my ex can I said oh yeah
there's this guy he around 50 marathons
in 50 states and 50 days was like no he
did I mean I didn't even hesitate like
well you're like are you trying to make
me feel like [ __ ] I was like no he's not
America
like you read that wrong there's no a
and and I just remember being just like
there wasn't anything more insane
someone could have said it you know I
mean like I don't even know I don't even
know how to respond to that you know so
I like Google Dean Card Asus and and I
read ultramarathon man and I saw running
on the Sun and running on the Sun just
and I don't know it's a documentary
about bad water oh yes I don't know
yeah can you is it online can people
yeah I think it's still out there if it
does I'll find a link I'll put it in the
show notes yeah sorry about that but uh
no go ahead yeah it man it just it
really it really touched something like
that scared me it scared me because I
thought that um I was probably gonna
want to do that one day mmm and that
scared they have little [ __ ] up mm-hmm
and so that seed was planted it really
was men rem-pod Dean's book yeah and
interestingly enough about that I talked
about full circle and just you know my
life is just you know tipped so far the
other direction that I mean I'm just I
can't even believe you know what my life
is today and I saw Marshall Ulrich on
that that film and he wrote the foreword
for my book and I met Marshall out at
bad water when I did it and it was just
so insane you know like I was like my
life is I have the most bizarre life in
the world you know it just seemed I mean
it's it really does feel like you know I
actually put it out there on a Facebook
post the other day I was like you ever
just realize you're absolutely 100%
living your dream life and that's the
way I feel I feel it's just I felt that
yesterday when I was sitting up in Dean
Hernandez's house doing a podcast with
him and he's talking to me and I'm
looking at him and I'm not hearing
anything that he's saying cuz I'm just
thinking what am I doing here you just
described the first five minutes yes for
me how did my life get to this point
where I'm sitting here having a
conversation with this guy like it just
it just hit me like
ton of bricks and in a beautiful way ya
know it's a heavy way to like you said
there's a certain amount of
responsibility that comes with but it
did not happen because I I plotted it
out don't write where I made some goal
and said I'm gonna do this like there
it's just there's just no way no you
know there's no way left to my own
devices that it happens no no you'd
screw it up I'm trying to derail it so
you see this movie and and and you read
Dean's book you know the movie is about
just how insane this bad water race is
the seeds planted and this is what 2007
ya know 2006 2006 still right yeah and
in your first bad water is 2013 yep
so we're talking about a seven year or
span here during which period of time
you run the Leadville 100 twice yes and
a bunch of other crazy stuff too
yeah so you're creating this you know
it's not the narrative the easy
narrative is you know three hundred and
twenty pounds to bad water you know
that'll probably be the title of my
blogpost but look at this subtitle
I know because well that's like you know
it's it sounds so crazy dramatic and and
it is but we're talking about many years
of brick by brick a lot of miles yeah I
never really exercised any level of
patience in my past life so I've been
trying you know and I didn't want to do
the same thing and just say this like
with the marathon I didn't want to go
okay well how can I go fake bad water
you know I didn't even know that you
couldn't fake that water that was really
hard which is race day registration but
yeah and then reading about Dean's book
and just reading about such a thing as
an ultramarathon I found out that the
Leadville 100 was right in my backyard
mm-hmm and it just seemed kind of kind
of shitty to get on a plane and fly
somewhere else to do an ultra when you
have one of the most iconic ones right
in your back all right and in certain
respects me
even I mean harder in a different way
with that crazy elevation and yeah it's
in air and everything else I mean what
was that what was that first light fell
like it was you know when I wrote the
book um the the finish line of my first
level was the finish line of the book
and and I actually I had to it was a
huge process of you know I'm getting
ahead of myself but but bad wad are
Leadville my first glad bill finish was
really the the true birth of me as as a
runner
um not that anything else I did before
wasn't you know running but it was that
moment that I really accepted that I
wasn't going to dismiss anything that
I've ever done but that I did I did and
I was gonna live that life anymore but
because up to that point like I did the
marathon and I was like okay what's next
and I did you know started doing
triathlon like okay what's next and I
was still searching and and so I think I
stopped searching at that point I just I
decided that I I was here and I just
needed to be here as much as I could I
needed to be in that moment and and be
and just own it
yeah well in a tangible way I mean you
went from running a marathon which is
something that hundreds of thousands of
people have done to running Leadville
which very very few people have done or
are capable of doing in the process of
getting thank you for saying that the
the process of getting there was was it
was wrought with lots of complications
along the way including though back
surgery and yeah you have the two
herniated discs yeah I mean there's
there's a lot you know we don't want to
have too many spoiler alerts yeah but
there's a lot yeah I mean there's a lot
of ups and down you you don't have to
read the book yeah we could be here for
eight hours yeah and I could I could
talk to you forever yeah thanks yeah
this is another example of how cool my
life is listen it's cool for me you know
this is this is awesome I'm fascinated
so so but walk me through the Leadville
I mean like you know paint a picture of
just how difficult that races
well training for the race was was more
difficult than I imagined and in fact it
smacked me down and humbled me and in a
big huge way and and there presented a a
moment where I was either gonna walk
away
and just go back to doing triathlons or
I was gonna you know step up and and do
some things differently and it's where I
got serious the next level of serious
you know and I changed my diet that's
when I adopted the plant-based diet
I went from 180 to 160 what was the
decision that drove that adair pretty
much a 30 day challenge by a friend
uh-huh and I was like you know and at
that point I was eating really clean I
mean I ate you know fruits vegetables
lean lean meats you know I really didn't
need much other than that and I had my
occasional thing I would you know have a
treat here and there but I mean 90% of
my diet was was what most people would
call super clean right and training a
ton and you just kind of stabilized at
180 yeah I'd been there for a few years
and I mean I felt fit and able to do you
know big runs and and things like that
had done some 50-miler 's and stuff like
that but um and then a dare like what
like no way could you possibly eat a
plant-based diet or not no just you know
from a friend like you who got tired of
me and asking him where he gets his
protein you know cuz he was a vegan and
he's like why don't you just do it for
30 days you know what are you afraid I
just try it see if it works for him I'm
like alright got nothing better to do
but if I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it
and I'm gonna do it and I actually did
it like more strict than he was doing it
cuz he wasn't he was telling me like
well every once in a while I'll do this
for that I'm like well if I'm gonna do
it I'm just gonna do it and I'm not
gonna have anything I'm not gonna
consume anything that has an animal any
trace amount of animal you were very
alcoholic about yes of course I was very
addict about it exactly and so I did it
for 30 days and I mean I felt like ice
on drugs I mean I felt so crazy good you
know I felt aware in light and fast and
my I was recovering for my workouts
better and you know lots of things were
changing at the same time I was changing
the volume of training I was changing my
mental focus and I changed my diet all
the same time and it was just like the
perfect storm I think for me as an
athlete and I just never looked back
I've said all along the day I feel I'm
missing something from my diet I'll go
have it you know I'm not on a moral
mission you know to make the world vegan
it's it's just about feeling better and
being healthy I understood a whole new
level of what health was interesting
yeah that and how long ago was that four
years four years and still haven't gone
back oh that's pretty cool yeah that's
pretty cool yeah I mean I like that
that's I like the openness you know the
idea that you're listening to your body
and this is working for you and if it
wasn't you would change you don't seem
to have a dogmatic approach to it but
rather a pretty you know scientific kind
of rational perspective on it and hey if
it's if you think it's making you faster
certainly you dropped an extra 20 pounds
so there's something right there but
that's cool I try to apply my insanity
and very logical way to grapple with
this over the next couple days there's a
difference between crazy and chemically
imbalanced it's be chemically imbalanced
you don't watch out for yeah after the
podcast would theme you know it wasn't
it wasn't a nutrition I mean I was
talking about how his nutrition has
changed but you know he's he's certainly
not vegan I mean he eats you know he's
kind of like it's what it sounds like
you were eating before you made the
switch but after we were done he's like
really you know like how does that work
and he was inquisitive like he's
interested but he was also very like
dubious like I want to see your
hematocrit right I'll send it to you
sterling but yeah I mean I feel the same
I feel the same way in the sense that if
my body started to feel like things
weren't working you know then I have to
be open enough to reevaluate like I have
to be willing to step outside you know
the label and the dogma you know I've
kind of painted myself into a corner
here with this thing you know I'm the
plant-based athlete guy but the truth of
the matter is it's been eight years and
it's been fantastic so I have no reason
to to you know
second guess it unless something changes
but so far so good and it's encouraging
and cool to hear that that's been part
of your journey yeah yeah a big
unexpected part of it that's you know
just I think made my life better and
different ways mm-hmm
I mean what what was you know when you
were going out and you're you were able
to recover better I mean you know is
there anything more specific just being
able to bounce back between big runs
yeah like just really tangible things of
noticing you know that I'm increasing my
level of my volume overall volume of
training I started doing you know two
three-hour runs several times a week and
I was okay and not just okay but getting
stronger and a lot of the trails that I
was you know hiking up because they were
super steep like I have this one route
bear peak and Boulder that I go up and I
was running things that I couldn't run
before you know and that's that's a real
difference it's like I struggle from
this section to this section and now I'm
I'm pushing it faster I'm going faster
and that's always like the big fear
especially if you dealt with injury in
your life that you're gonna increase
your training volume and you're just
gonna go backwards so I was very I had
to learn the hard way that if my brain
is tired you know if it's my brain
pushing back at me but I keep going but
if it's my body pushing back I listen to
it mm-hmm that's a that's a hard thing
to balance have you do you work with a
coach how do you come up with your
training protocol yeah I do I think
coaching is is a very valuable tool you
know and you know Michael Jordan had a
coach and everybody has a coach and you
just I can't trust myself to manage me
you know in that way so yeah I've I've
benefited greatly from having Marshall
Ulrich oh he's your coach my in my
rolodex cool he doesn't have time to be
full-time coach but I certainly bounced
all of my training by him or through him
and get his input on it and you know
like when I was I did a 12 hour
treadmill run recently I try to set the
world record on that and I bounced that
by Marshall I didn't know that he's like
you got to do a year back-to-back long
runs on the treadmill and I'm like damn
it he's right but I would have never
done that myself you know
hold on a second you tried to break the
12-hour treadmill record yeah
how'd that go what did you set the
American one oh you did well it depends
I mean there's there's two a couple
different sources that track you know
all of the difference right so I was
going for the Guinness record and it was
a quite honestly kind of a soft record
so I knew it was kind of some
low-hanging fruit is like 63 miles and I
was gonna try to run 72 73 miles which
is no decent and what happened is two
days before it somebody else broke the
record hmm and so they reported that he
had run 90 miles mm-hmm I was like you
know I had all my friends out at my gym
and I had this big thing set up and I
was like that's alright I'm just gonna
go do the best I can I wasn't doing it
just for the recognition I was doing it
to test myself and I ran 70 4.5 miles
something that turns out that the
numbers were reported wrong and he'd
only around 76 miles so yeah yeah that
kind of sucked you got to do it again
I am in January you are all right boy
and when you want when you want it to be
guinness-certified that's a whole thing
okay it's on of money and they want all
sorts of people that like I know when
because when Patrick baboom Ian wanted
to break that most weight carry you know
it was a whole thing to like make sure
that it was all like copacetic and about
like it was gonna meet the requirements
to qualify for that because they it's
pretty stringent right it is it's really
strict you don't have to give them a
bunch of money if you don't want to but
it speeds the process up know what I
mean though like you know certify the
record right away and they'll send
someone out and you can use their logos
and marketing and obviously but no we
had to have like the whole thing had to
be video recorded and I needed witnesses
and judges and you know obviously the
trial calibrate the treadmill and all
that kind of stuff yeah
so there's another place called like
record holders board that tracks it
according to their information I think I
ran like the third best time by an
American them nice maron to Guinness it
was that's insane yeah that's so cool
for a former fat guy right that's
incredible man but I mean there's
there's so many other people who have
run some
farther than that out there but listen
there's always somebody who's done some
crazier thing especially now in the
ultra world like you know there's no end
you know I mean if you can find you know
a stone that's unturned in that world
and that's a stone worth overturning I
think so alright so a couple levels
badwater 2013 and then you went back to
bad water this year yeah didn't things
go things didn't quite go as planned I
mean what is what's next like what
what's getting you out of bed what's
motivating you like what is the what is
that stone that's left unturned out
there for you well to me it's to stay in
the game and to keep in the process
right I would say you know my running my
journey it's not supposed to be anything
it just is what it is so I just want to
keep going whatever that means
so I'm always aware and looking around
for for new things to do and and I do
have something kind of big plan for for
next year it's my tenth sober birthday
hmm so I wanted to do something kind of
special for that little smile I tell you
don't really want to tell me but you
kind of do okay so I decided that I was
gonna go try to run the Leadville 100
twice I was gonna do the do the double
whoa and the reason why I haven't put it
out there is not because I'm afraid of
it or it's out there now but it will be
when I'm out now that's fine you know
I've got alright people about it but you
know people have done double bad water
trip yeah yeah quad man water all that
but no one's done Leadville so nobody's
done a double Leadville no-one's done it
so I'm sure some will come along and do
it really really fast but that's okay
I'd like to be the first person to do it
but if someone comes up to out there and
and does it at the same time I do then
we'll just show the trail together
mm-hmm
but I hope no one doesn't that's pretty
cool man
that's a big deal yeah exciting yeah so
wait wait when is Leadville again August
August okay so
you got a little time it has to be
training pretty hard right now though
I've got javelina hundred mm-hmm in a
few days when I got some other I got the
treadmill run plant to hundreds and I'll
be back at bad water to mmm we're a
little unsure exactly when it's gonna be
with new new changes to the park but
yeah interesting yeah yeah in 2013 you
ran what is probably the last time than
anyone will run that original course I
think it actually is gonna be back in
the original course oh really yeah it's
just gonna be different because the the
new study they did and everything won't
let him do it
between June and July or something I
don't want to misquote the study but but
they can't have it in the in the hottest
part of year so they could have it in
August then instead or something yeah
they're gonna do something and no one
really knows what yet it's kind of
hush-hush I don't know but hopefully
it's not you know the week before LED
built or something like that cos right
right I mean what was the biggest
difference that you noticed from the
course change from thirteen to fourteen
it was just a different race it was a
great race it was is put on really well
it was really challenging super
challenging but you know it was hot but
not bad water hot mm-hmm and the heat
came late in the day which definitely
posed different you know different
challenges and the first like 23 miles
is straight uphill right that was the ya
know that's kind of my problem is I ran
the first 46 miles in like eight hours
this year and right and then just kind
of fell apart like it the worst possible
time there's another big climb that goes
up like five thousand feet over seven
miles and there's no crew access or
anything you just kind of out there and
that's when I was really suffering
mm-hmm
just another learning experience it you
know gotta go back
unfinished business that's right I want
to get back to this idea of
transformation of reinvention you know
you went from this place of complete
despair complete you know disrepair in
your health to you know
attempting Guinness Book of World Record
holding runs I mean the arc is is just
mind-blowing
so for somebody who's out there
listening you know what is what is
something that you could leave us with
to try to help that person out there
who's stuck who can't take that first
step or just is paralyzed you know knows
that there's a better life for him or
her out there and can't see their way
through it my advice would be that you
don't have to see it you know in fact
you probably won't be able to ever see
it from the views obstructed right you
can't see it from where you are that you
have to trust that there is a way out
and that it's not always gonna seem
hopeless and you just have to take that
blind first step forward and that's
that's why this ultra thing speaks so
well to me because the process is the
same you know the process was the same
to wake up on my bathroom floor and say
I'm gonna I'm gonna give this all up as
it is to line up for bad water you know
if you you try to hold the weight of it
crush you and fold you up and you know
you can't do it so you got to trust the
process and and just be willing to not
wrestle every single voice every single
thought down into the ground and just
just keep moving forward blindly and you
know that was the process when you
talked about that that arc you know I
became a runner and did all these things
after I found sobriety and I did that
because I changed kind of my image of
who I was I decided I was a different
person
but then I realized that I had also
pigeon-holed who I was as a runner too
and I was I'm I'm just doing this you
know because you know I'm always gonna
be slow I used to joke you know I'm I
start out slow and then I taper off and
you know all this kind of stuff and I
was like well maybe that's not true
either you know maybe maybe that's just
a bunch of crap I sold myself to so you
know I'm gonna put it out there and just
see what happens and if I'm if I can't
be any faster that's fine but I'm not
gonna not be faster because I decided I
was before I ever tried it so don't
decide who you are you know the
because of where you are right now
mm-hmm that's beautifully put you know I
think that that the approach that I take
to sobriety is the same approach that I
take to food is the same approach that I
take to training and what you learn in
recovery is as stupid as it sounds and
it's really [ __ ] stupid it's one day
at a time as you know it's about making
sure that my head hits that pillow
tonight sober and that's all I got to
worry about in the context of food what
am i eating right now what's my next
meal in the context of training what's
the run or the ride that I'm doing today
if I start thinking about some crazy
race you know you just get you you you
get scared you get stuck you start
running stories and scenarios in your
mind that you know probably are not
productive
so I find it super helpful to just be in
the moment of what you're doing and
getting comfortable with the idea that
you don't know where it's going and or
should you you know it's like part of
that surrender is saying I'm not gonna
drink today I don't know what that means
but that's not what I you know I'm not
somebody who drinks I'm not doing that
today and it's not what you say it's
what you do absolutely and when you wake
up every day and you go running or you
wake up every day and you don't take a
drink then you string that together over
a little period of time and the story
about who you are begins to change and
the way that people interact with you
begins to change and how you start to
feel about who you are begins to change
absolutely yeah it's beautiful and then
a whole new journey takes place right
you learned something you don't know
about yourself mmm David Clarke you are
in inspiration now this was awesome
thank you so much thanks man you're
coming down I really appreciate it
the book is called out there and you can
find it everywhere it's on Amazon right
yes in bookstores I highly recommend it
it's amazing it's amazing story of like
I said before despair - triumph it's
pretty cool I can't wait to see what
you're gonna do next man thanks you know
I've said all along that ultimately the
the most power that the story has
as if it's it's not just me you know I'm
not the only one with this story
especially sitting here talking to you
well there's lots of people with this
story I just get lucky enough to be able
to talk about it a lot if it's just one
person you know it's all that guy
specially no he said he's just he's just
stubborn or whatever he's got something
that I don't but that's just not the way
it is you know there's a lot of us out
there and so the more the merrier if if
you're out there running and doing crazy
things and experiencing life and you
want some other people to to do it with
no we're there
mm-hmm very cool man all right David
thanks so much
write-up piece yeah plants that was
stuff Dave you will be deeply profoundly
missed but you are loved immensely by
myself and so many people so run free my
friend run free if you want to support
Dave and his family pick up one of his
books out there broken open or his
newest book eat [ __ ] and die I think
that's a great way to keep Dave in our
hearts and also support his family in
addition as we mentioned in the intro
Mishka and Josh and I set up a GoFundMe
I'll put a link in the show notes to
that please support if you can and
remember life is short life is precious
so let's make the most out of every
moment that we can my friends and on May
30 let's try to get outside run whatever
you can to honor this beautiful man's
legacy see back here in a couple days
with another episode until then peace
plants grace